हेलो एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी गुड
इवनिंग टू
ऑल एंड आफ्टर लॉन्ग
टाइम तो सबसे पहले मुझे य बताइए सबको मेरी
आवाज सुनाई दे रही है आई एम ऑडिबल लाउड
एंड
क्लियर प्लीज बताइए जल्दी से
आई एम फाइन अब्दुल बट आई वाज बिजी इन सम
वेयर एल्स ओके
तो क्लास नहीं ले पाया कुछ दिन तक क्योंकि
मैं काफी बिजी था मुझे टाइम नहीं था तो
डोंट वरी फिर से हम कंटिन्यू करेंगे तब तक
के लिए आपको टाइम मिल गया होगा खुद से
किसी के कोई एग्जाम हो गए या बाकी कुछ
होगा तो शायद आप लोगों को टाइम मिल गया
होगा खुद के लिए
अजय वेरी गुड इवनिंग वेरी गुड इवनिंग तो
आज हम एक फ्रेश टॉपिक से स्टार्ट करेंगे
अपनी क्लास को और प्रीवियस टॉपिक जो हमारा
था व रिलेटेड टू द एक्सप्लोइट कि
एक्सप्लोइट होते क्या है और कैसे उनको हम
सर्च करते हैं पब्लिकली अवेलेबल डेटाबेस
से वह सब मैंने आपको बताया था बट कुछ
इंपोर्टेंट
बच गया था जैसे कि हाउ टू कंपाइल एंड
क्रॉस कंपाइल ऑफ द एक्सप्लोइट हाउ टू
फिक्स द
एक्सप्लोइट मुझे लगा कि आज उसको कवर नहीं
करना चाहिए क्योंकि आप लोग
शायद शायद आप मुझे लगता कि आप लोग
इंटरेस्ट नहीं दिखाते तो इसलिए मैंने सोचा
कि डे 24 है जो एक नए और फ्रेश टॉपिक के
साथ स्टार्ट करनी चाहिए और उसके बाद हम
कंटिन्यू करेंगे इन बिटवीन उसको मैं
डिलीवर कर दूंगा कुछ भी आपके जो सेश है को
कहीं पर भी बीच में ब्रेक नहीं करूंगा इन
द सेंस कि कहीं पर जो आपका टॉपिक बीच में
पढ़ाना था उसको नहीं छोडूंगा मैं उसको
पढ़ाऊंगा जरूर डेफिनेटली क्योंकि अभी
लिनक्स हमारा काफी बचा हुआ है नक् हैकिंग
जिसकी बात कर रहे हैं हम
लिनक्स में विंडोज के हैकिंग स्टार्ट
करेंगे तो बब जा तब जाके हमारा जो सिस्टम
हैकिंग की कंसेप्ट है क्लियर होगा तो अभी
काफी कुछ सीखने को बजा हुआ है फंडामेंटल्स
में भी आपका
तो बनी आपको नोट्स बनाने की वैसे तो जरूरत
नहीं है क्योंकि यह सारी स्लाइड्स आपको
मिल जाती है डिफरेंस अकेडमी के ऊपर जस्ट
पे योर 0 और आई थिंक कि मैं प्रीवियस
क्लास की कुछ दो या तीन क्लास की मैं शायद
नहीं अपलोड कर पाया हूं बिकॉज ऑफ माय नॉन
अवेलेबिलिटी तो बट डेफिनेटली आई विल मेक
श्यर कि नेक्स्ट बिफोर नेक्स्ट क्लास आई
विल अपलोड ऑल द स्लाइड्स तो इंक्लूडिंग जो
आज वाली भी है
तो दे आर 25 स्टूडेंट्स
ओनली तो आफ्टर लॉन्ग टाइम फिर भी क्या है
25 स्टूडेंट्स ही हैं आई डोंट नो कि
स्टूडेंट्स कहां रहते हैं और क्या करते
हैं इट्स ओके हम सेशन को कंटिन्यू करेंगे
तो एक से दो मिनट का वेट करते हैं तब तक
के लिए आपको कोई भी सवाल है मुझसे पूछ
सकते हैं उसके बाद हम सेशन को कंटिन्यू
करंगे फॉर योर काइंड इंफॉर्मेशन यह एक
जीरो टू इंटरमीडिएट लेवल का कोर्स है उसके
बाद हम एडवांस लेवल या प्रोफेशनल लेवल की
बात कर सकते हैं एडवांस तो उससे आगे हो
जाता है तो प्रोफेशनल लेवल का भी हम कोस्ट
डिलीवर करेंगे बट फ्री में नहीं करेंगे या
तो पूरा कोस्ट डिलीवर करेंगे या उसको हम
वर्कशॉप के रूप में या बूट कैंप के रूप
में डिलीवर करेंगे छोटे-छोटे टाइम
ड्यूरेशन के लिए 10 टू 15 डेज 20 डेज या
वन वीक लाइक दैट जिससे क्या होगा कि आपके
जो कांसेप्ट हैं व सारे क्लियर हो जाएंगे
उसके बाद जब प्रोफेशन बेसिक के बाद जब
प्रोफेशन में शिफ्ट करोगे तो उन वर्कशॉप
से आपको काफी हेल्प मिलेगी अपने करियर
में नहीं मैंने जो कुछ बताया बेसिक चीजें
बताता हूं तो हम अप्लाई करते हैं तो व
वर्क नहीं करते कहां पर वर्क नहीं करते
शायद इवनली जो मैंने जितने भी लैब सॉल्व
किए है सब में वर्क प्रैक्टिकली आपके
सामने शो किया है
शायद यह क्लेम तो आपका गलत है कि मैं जो
आपको सिखा रहा हूं और वह काम नहीं
करता मैंने आपको कुछ भी गलत नहीं सिखाया
है तो लाइव है पन टेस्टिंग में एक चीज
बताइए ना आप फायर वल को कंसीडर करते ही
नहीं
लाइव वेबसाइट पन टेस्टिंग के केस में आपने
जो मैं आपको सिखा रहा हूं जब सिस्टम
हैकिंग में तो मैंने आपको एक्सएसएस और
एसक्यूएल तो नहीं बताया मैंने आपको यह
बताया है कि अगर आपके पास सेल एक्सेस है
अगर आपके पास आपने एक्सप्लोइट कर लिया या
आपको एक्सप्लोइट मिल गया तो उस एक्सप्लोइट
को फर्द आप क्या करोगे आपने एक्सप्लोइटेशन
कर लिया तो फर्द आप सेल एक्सेस कैसे लोगे
तो वो मैंने आपको बताया और अगर आप सेल
एक्सेस मिल जाता है तो उसके बाद आप क्या
कर सकते हो
और अगर प वेब पेंटेस्टिंग की बात करते हो
वेबसाइट में अगर आपको कोई वनटी मिली ही
नहीं है आपने कोई उससे रिलेटेड वेब
एक्सप्लोइट फाइंड आउट किया ही नहीं है तो
आप कैसे अप्लाई करोगे इस कांसेप्ट को
बिकॉज देखिए वेब पन टेस्टिंग आप करते हो
क्योंकि एक ही तरीका है एक तो आपका कि वेब
पन टेस्टिंग के थ्रू आप किसी भी सर्वर को
एक्सक्लूड कर सकते हो अब दूसरा तरीका क्या
होता है दूसरा तरीका जिसको हम क्लाइंट
साइड अटैक्स बोलते हैं और अभी शायद आप
क्लाइंट साइड के वह अटैक सीख रहे हो जो
जैसे कि पब्लिक फेसिंग सर्वर के थ्रू आप
अटैक करना सीख रहे हो और वेब पन टेस्टिंग
तो मैं आपको पढ़ाया नहीं मैंने अभी तक और
वेब पन टेस्टिंग अगर आपको सीखना है तो
नितेश सर ऑलरेडी करवा रहे हैं बग बाउंट
सीरीज को आप कंसीडर कर सकते हो कि वो वेब
पंड टेस्टिंग में भी बहुत हेल्पफुल है कुछ
अलग नहीं होता तो बेसिक लेवल प वो वही
कोर्स का पार्ट है तो वेब प टेस्टिंग में
सिर्फ वही है वा वास टॉप 10 आपको पता होना
चाहिए मेरी तरफ से मेरे कोर्स की तरफ से
और वो निते सर ऑलरेडी कवर कर चुके हैं
एक्सएसएस एसक्यूएल और एडवांस लेवल पर
मैंने आपको कभी कुछ डिलीवर किया नहीं अभी
तक तो जब तक आप किसी भी वेबसाइट से
रिलेटेड एक्सप्लोइट नहीं फाइंड आउट कर
पाओगे तब तक आप उसके अंदर क्या कर पाओगे
कोई भी सेल कोड इंसर्ट नहीं कर पाओगे खास
कर के रिवर्स सेल और अभी तक तो मैंने आपको
किसी चीज को एक्सप्लोइट किया ही नहीं है
जस्ट जितने भी लैब मैंने आपके सामने
रिप्रेजेंट किए हैं दे टोटल फोर लैब्स सब
मैंने ओपनली अवेलेबल इंफॉर्मेशन को यूज
करके आपको मैंने सिखाया है कि आप कैसे
अप्रोच बना सकते हो रियल लाइफ में अब रियल
लाइफ में तो आपको बहुत कुछ करना पड़ेगा
एप्लीकेशन के साथ आपने ऑफस केशन भी भी
करना पड़ता है इजन भी करना पड़ता है बहुत
सारी चीजें करनी पड़ती है बहुत सारे टूल्स
होते हैं बहुत सार टेक्निक्स होती हैं और
फिर भी गारंटी नहीं होती कि आप उसको
सक्सेसफुली कर पाओगे या नहीं कर पाओगे समझ
रहे हो क्योंकि उसके लिए आपको बहुत कुछ
आना
चाहिए भा पलब कई दिन से मैंने अपने लिंकन
प्रोफाइल को ओपन नहीं किया है कई दिन से
नहीं किया मैंने सॉरी फॉर दैट क्योंकि मैं
अभी कई दिन से लिंक दिन पर नहीं कर पाया
हूं हां आदित्य दिस इज बिगनर फेसिंग बट
जैसे कि मैं आपको एक
चीज एक चीज बताऊंगा जैसे कि मैं एक
वर्कशॉप लेकर आऊंगा जब क्लाइंट साड टक्स
उसमें मैं सोशल इंजीनियरिंग प्लस में ब्र
टीमिंग का एक कॉमिनेशन है जो उसका कुछ
ड्यूरेशन रहेगा आप उसमें सीखना हम
प्रैक्टिकली एक ऐसा अटैक परफॉर्म करने की
कोशिश करेंगे जो पॉसिबल भी
है ओके तो अभी हम सेशन को कंटिन्यू करते
हैं
और ऊपर से क्या कि अगर आप कोई भी एग्जाम
दोगे पेन टेस्टिंग का तो दे आर वेरी वेरी
हेल्पफुल
ओके साइबर हब वेरी गुड मॉर्निंग एंड
कृष्णा वेरी गुड इवनिंग
एंड ओके क्लास को स्टार्ट करें अभी देर
एनफ स्टूडेंट्स
इस कोर्स को कंप्लीट करने के बाद ये जो
ईजीपी लेवल का कोर्स है ठीक है आप ईजीपी
का एग्जाम दे सकते हो वेरी वेल और सीच की
तरफ आपको जाने की जरूरत नहीं है क्योंकि
आज के टाइम में नॉट रिकमेंडेबल क्योंकि
अभी इतना वैल्यू नहीं है उसका सच में उससे
अच्छा तो ईजी पीटी का एग्जाम है बट उसके
बाद आप एडवांस मूव कर सकते हो और एडवांस
में क्या है कि इसकी बहुत स टेक्निक्स
होती है जैसे कि एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी पन
टेस्टिंग होती है क्लाइंट साइड अटैक
नेटवर्क पन टेस्टिंग और जैसे आपके लेटरल
मूवमेंट्स होते हैं विज और
[संगीत]
डिपेंडेंट आप एक लेवल प हो सकते हो
क्योंकि एंटीवायरस और आजकल के सिक्योरिटी
सोल्यूशन को बायपास करना नॉट एन इजी जॉब
क्योंकि एक चूहे और बिल्ली का खेल है ठीक
है तो हिट एंड ट्रायल का ही खेल है तो हर
कोई अभी एक मैं एक कोर्स पढ़ाऊंगा अगर मैं
कोर्स में बताता भी हूं तो उसको सोचो कि
उस चीज को कितने लोग अप्लाई करते हैं एट ए
टाइम स्टूडेंट्स उसको अप्लाई करते हैं तो
धीरे-धीरे वो टेक्निक्स के एंटीवायरस के
उस में आ जाती है डिटेक्शन में अब बोलते
हैं वो टेक्नीक काम नहीं करती क्योंकि
भैया मेरे लिए वो काम की हो आपके लिए
इसलिए काम नहीं कर रही क्योंकि एट टाइम
100 स्टूडेंट्स उसको ट्राई कर रहे हैं और
एक बार एंटीवायरस के डेटाबेस में व अपलोड
हो गया तो फवा को डिटेक्ट करता ही करता
है ओके तो हम स्टार्ट करते हैं
अभी तो आज का जो हमारा इंपोर्टेंट टॉपिक
है उसका नाम है यह रहा
बाइड एंड रिवर्स सेल
जो मोस्ट इंपोर्टेंट फंडामेंटल टॉपिक है
किसी भी टैकर्स के लिए या बात करें
पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर्स और एथिकल हैकर्स के
लिए सबसे मोस्ट इंपॉर्टेंट फंडामेंटल
टॉपिक है जिसके बारे में आपको पता ही होना
चाहिए क्योंकि कभी भी आपको इसकी जरूरत पड़
सकती है इवन योर एग्जाम एग्जाम में आपकी
आपको जरूरत पड़ती है आप चाहे जीपीटी दोगे
या आप ओससीपी दोगे तो उन एग्जाम्स में की
जरूरत पड़नी ही पड़नी है क्योंकि आपको
रिवर्स सेल और बाइंडर चाहिए ही चाहिए होते
हैं तो बाइन सेल और रिवर्स सेल के बारे
में डिस्कस करने से पहले एक मोस्ट
इंपोर्टेंट टॉपिक है एक मोस्ट मोस्ट
इंपोर्टेंट वेरी वेरी इंपोर्टेंट जिसको हम
बोल सकते हैं एक टूल है जिसके बारे में
हमें डिस्कस करना है क्योंकि जब भी हम
बाइन सेल और रिवर्स सेल को एस्टेब्लिश
करने की बात करते हैं कि जब अब इस प्रोसेस
को फॉलो करते हैं कि अगर मुझे बाइन सेल और
रिवर्स सेल चाहिए किसी भी म के ऊपर तो हम
उस कांसेप्ट को यूज करते ही करते हैं
जिसकी मैं बात कर रहा हूं उस टूल का हम
नॉर्मली यूज करते ही करते हैं उस टूल का
नाम आपका नेटकट सबने सुना होगा उसका नाम
नेटकट लेकिन सबसे पहले हम उसके बारे में
डिस्कस करते हैं कि नेटकट होता क्या है और
कैसे उसको यूज किया जाता है और कैसे वह
काम करता है उसके बाद हम सीखेंगे कि बाइन
सेल और रिवर्स सेल्स होते क्या हैं थ्योरी
प्लस प्रैक्टिकली हम बात करेंगे तो सबसे
पहले हम बात करते हैं कि नेट कट
फंडामेंटल्स ट इ
नेटकट नेटकट इज ए स्विस आर्मी नाइफ
टीसीपीआईपी स्विस आर्मी नाइफ हम नेटकट को
एक टीसीपी आर्मी स्फ नाइ ट टूल भी बोल
सकते हैं इट इज ए नेटवर्किंग यूटिलिटी यूज
टू रीड एंड राइट डाटा टू नेटवर्क कनेक्शन
यूजिंग टीसीपी और यूडीपी बेसिकली नेट कट
एक नेटवर्किंग यूटिलिटी है जिसका यूज हम
डाटा को रीड और राइट करने के लिए करते हैं
यूजिंग योर नेटवर्क कनेक्शन जो आपका
एसिस्टिंग नेटवर्क कनेक्शन है उसके ऊपर
टीसीपी और यूडीपी की हेल्प से अगर हमें
डाटा को रीड और राइट करना है तो हम इस
नेटवर्क यूटिलिटी का यूज कर सकते हैं टकट
इज अवेलेबल फॉर बोथ
काफी गुड क्रॉस प्लेटफॉर्म टूल है इट इज
कंपलीटली
एग्नोर क्या है यू कैन इजली ऑब्टेन ए
रिवर्स सेल ऑन ए विंडोज सिस्टम इवन इफ यू
आर रनिंग ए
की कमांड रन कर सकते हैं उसका सेल लेकर
अगर आप विंडोज मशीन को यूज कर रहे हो कर
रहे हैं तो नेट कट की हेल्प से आप क्या कर
सकते हो रिवर्स सेल क्रिएट कर सकते हैं
की रिवर्स सेल और बाइन सेल कि अभी आप बोलो
सर ये नेट नेट कट काम कैसे करता है और
क्या रिलेशनशिप है कि मैं रिवर्स सेल और
बाइन सेल सेट अप करूंगा लेकिन मैं
कांसेप्ट नेटकट का पढ़ रहा हूं क्योंकि
अभी यह चीज समझने के लिए आपको सबसे पहले
समझना होगा कि नेटकट का कम्युनिकेशन मॉडल
कैसे काम करता है जब तक आपको यह नहीं पता
कि नेट कट काम कैसे करता है वो कम्युनिकेट
कैसे करता है या उसका जो मॉड्यूल है वो
कैसे काम करता है तब तक आप यह समझ ही नहीं
नहीं पाओगे कि जो बाइन सेल है और जो
रिवर्स सेल है उनको जब हम एस्टेब्लिश करते
हैं या जब सेट अप करते हैं तो हम नेट कट
क्यों पढ़ते हैं या नेट कट को क्यों यूज
करते हैं तो यह चीज मैं आपको अभी क्लियर
करके देता
हूं नाउ देखिए नेट कट यूटिलाइज ए क्लाइंट
सर्वर कम्युनिकेशन आर्किटेक्चर विद टू
मोड्स बेसिकली जो आपका नेट कट है वो
क्लाइंट सर्वर आर्किटेक्चर पर काम करता है
जिसके अंदर दो मोड्स है एक तो क्लाइंट मोड
होता है एक सर्वर मोड होता है क्लाइंट मोड
में क्या करता है नेटकट कैन बी यूज्ड इन
क्लाइंट मोड टू कनेक्ट टू एनी टीसीपी
यूडीपी पोर्ट एज वेल एज नेट कट लिनर
बेसिकली जब आप नेट कट को क्लाइंट मोड में
यूज करते हैं तो उसके उस केस में क्या
करते हो आप किसी भी टीसीपी और यूडीपी
पोर्ड से कनेक्ट कर सकते हैं साथ के साथ
या जो नेट कट लिसन जो सर्वर मोड है उसको
भी क्या कर सकते हो आप कने कर सकते हो अब
सर्वर मोड की बात करें नेट कट कैन बी यूज
टू लिसन फॉर कनेक्शंस फ्रॉम क्लाइंट ऑन ए
स्पेसिफिक पोर्ट अब सर्वर मोड में क्या
करते हो आप एक लिनर सेटअप करते हो जिससे
कोई भी क्ट क्लाइंट क्या कर सकता
है कनेक्ट हो सकता है बेसिकली नेटकट
क्लाइंट कनेक्ट हो सकता है तो क्लाइंट मोड
में क्या करता है कि जो क्लाइंट है वह
किसी भी टीसीपी या यूडीपी पोर्ट से क्या
कर सकता है कनेक्ट हो सकता है या जहां पर
नेटकट लिनर ऑन है जहां पर सर्वर का काम
क्या है सर्वर क्या करता है बेसिकली सर्व
करता है और एक स्पेसिफिक सर्विस प्रोवाइड
करता है और सर्विस से रिलेटेड एक पोर्ट
होता है उस पोर्ट पर क्या करता है लिसन
करता है वही काम यहां पर नेटकट सर्वर मोड
का है कि वो एक स्पेसिफिक पोर्ट पे एक
स्पेसिफिक सर्विसेस के लिए सर्विस नहीं
बोल सकते ले एक स्पेसिफिक पोर्ट पर क्या
करता है लिसन करता है और जैसे ही नेटकट
क्लाइंट उससे कनेक्ट होने की कोशिश करता
है तो वो कनेक्ट हो जाता है कनेक्शन
एस्टेब्लिश कर लेता है तो यह है इसका
क्लाइंट सर्वर कम्युनिकेशन मॉडल नेट नेट
कट कैन बी यूज्ड बाय पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर्स
टू परफॉर्म द फॉलोइंग फंक्शन अभी जो नेट
कट है पेन टेस्टर के द्वारा यह सारी
फंक्शन परफॉर्म करने के लिए यूज किया जाता
है खासकर जैसे कि बैनर ग्रैबिंग पोर्ट
स्कैनिंग ट्रांसफरिंग फाइल्स बाइंडर
रिवर्स सेल्स इसलिए नेट कट पढ़ना जरूरी था
है कि आप नेट कट की हेल्प से बैनर
ग्रैबिंग भी कर सकते हो पोर्ट स्कैनिंग भी
कर सकते हो फाइल ट्रांसफर भी कर सकते हो
और इवन बाइड और रिवर्स सेल भी गेट इन कर
सकते हो तो नाउ अभी हम समझते हैं चलो बैनर
ग्रबिंग क्या होता है तो सबसे पहले मुझे
बताइए कि नेट कट के बारे में जो आपको
बताया कि नेट कट होता क्या है और नेट कट
कैसे काम करता है एवरीवन क्लियर प्लीज
बताइए जल्दी
से बताइए बताइए ब जिस क्लास के एंड में आप
प्रीवियस क्लास रिलेटेड मुझसे क्वेश्चन
पूछ सकते हैं नो इशू आई विल आंसर योर
क्वेश्चन ओके
किसी को कोई डाउट है मुझसे पूछ सकता है
अभी रिलेटेड टू द कांसेप्ट करंट
कांसेप्ट प्लीज जितने भी स्टूडेंट्स है
सभी रिप्लाई कीजिए चैट
में ताकि मुझे पता चल जाएगा कि आप लोगों
को क्लियर
है देखो क्लाइंट मोड में क्या होता है कि
आप सिंपली कनेक्ट कनेक्शन क्रिएट करते हो
बेसिकली क्या कि आप क्या करते हो अभी मैं
एग्जांपल लेता हूं कि आप वेबसाइट होस्ट कर
दी सर्वर के ऊपर और जब आप क्या करते हो
ब्राउजर के थ्रू क्या करते हो उस वेबसाइट
पर क्या f.com किया फॉर एग्जांपल और यह
होस्टेड है एक डोमेन पर wwf.com तो आप
सिंपली क्या करते हो अपने लैपटॉप में
fix.com भरते हो तो डायरेक्टली क्या करता
है वो सर्वर के साथ कनेक्ट कनेक्शन
क्रिएटर तो बेसिकली जब आप अपने ब्राउजर के
थ्रू फ पर जाते हो तो आप एक क्लाइंट हो
लेकिन जो य सर्विस प्रोवाइड कर रहा व एक
सर्वर मोड है तो सेम मैकेनिज्म यहां पर
काम करता
है नहीं इट इ नॉट कॉम्प्लिकेटेड ब्रो
इसमें क्या कॉम्प्लिकेशन
है अब्दुल सिंपल वर्ड्स में वी कैन से ट
की नेटकट एक ऐसी नेटवर्क यूटिलिटी है
जिससे हम नेटवर्क कनेक्शन के ऊपर नेटवर्क
कनेक्शन के द्वारा टीसीपी और यूडीपी
प्रोटोकॉल की हेल्प से डाटा को रीड और
राइट कर सकते हैं बस सिंपल यह इसकी
डेफिनेशन है यह क्लाइंट सर्वर के मॉड्यूल
पर काम करता है ठीक है इसमें दो दो मोड
होते हैं एक तो क्लाइंट मोड होता है एक
सर्वर मोड होता है यह सर्वर की तरह भी
एक्ट कर सकता है और क्लाइंट की तरह भी
एक्ट कर सकता है
ओके तो अभी हम बात करते हैं कि बैनर
ग्रबिंग की तो मैंने एक शब्द का यूज किया
था बैनर ग्रबिंग क्या होता है बैनर
ग्रैबिंग इज एन इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग
टेक्निक यूज्ड बाय पेनिट्रेशन टेस्टर टू
इनमेट इंफॉर्मेशन रिगार्डिंग द टारगेट
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम एज वेल एज सर्विसेस दैट
आर रनिंग ऑन इट्स ओपन पोर्ट बैनर ग्रैबिंग
क्या है जब आप इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग करते हो
तो उसी टेक्निक का एक पार्ट है खास कर के
एन्यूमरेशन के दौरान आप क्या करते हो बैनर
ग्रैबिंग करते हो और बैनर ग्रैबिंग की
हेल्प से आप क्या करते हो टारगेट ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम के बारे में इंफॉर्मेशन
अ गैदर करते हो और साथ के साथ जो ओपन
पोर्ट्स है उसके ऊपर जो सर्विसेस अवेलेबल
है उसके बारे में इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट
करने की कोशिश करते हो जो मेन ऑब्जेक्टिव
है आपका बैनर ग्रैबिंग का इज टू
आइडेंटिफिकेशन स रनिंग ऑन ए स्पेसिफिक
पोर्ट एज वेल एज सर्विस वर्जन ओके यह इसका
मेन ऑब्जेक्टिव है बैनर ग्रैबिंग कैन बी
परफॉर्म थ्रू वेरियस टेक्निक फॉर फर्स्ट
परफॉर्मिंग ए सर्विस वर्जन डिटेक्शन स्कैन
विद ए मैप जो मैंने लास्ट क्लास में आपको
बताया था कि हम एनम की हेल्प से सर्विस
वर्जन डिटेक्शन कर सकते हैं तो यह एक बैनर
ग्रैबिंग का एग्जांपल है कनेक्टिंग टू द
ओपन पोर्ट्स विद नेट कट दूसरा हम नेट कट
की हेल्प से भी बैनर ग्रैबिंग कर सकते हैं
जो ओपन पोर्ट्स अवेलेबल हैं तो उनको ट कड
की हेल्प से हम कनेक्ट करने की कोशिश कर
सकते हैं कई बार क्या होता है कि जो
सर्विसेस होती हैं वो अपना बैनर यूज करती
है जिनसे क्या होता है कि जैसे आप ओपन
पोर्ट को कनेक्ट करने की कोशिश करोगे वहां
पर आपको उसका सर्विस बैनर देखने को मिलेगा
जरूरी नहीं है लेकिन सम टाइम्स आपको मिल
जाता है अगर वो सर्विस बैन देखने को मिलता
है वहां पर कई बार आपको देखने को मिलता है
कि फॉर एग्जांपल एसएसए ही है तो ओपन एसएसए
7.2.4 समथिंग और यह ब्रैकेट में वनटू या
विंडोज लाइक दैट आपको देखने को मिल जाता
है तो कई वहां से भी क्या आपको एक
इंपॉर्टेंट इंफॉर्मेशन देखने को मिल जाती
है अब ऑथेंटिकेटिंग विद द सर्विसेस या
आपको पता है एसएसएस एफटीपी ऑथेंटिकेशन
प्रोटोकॉल का यूज करते हैं तो सिंपली आप
क्या करते हो आप डायरेक्टली रैंडम उनको
कनेक्ट करने की कोशिश करते हो फिर रॉन्ग
पासवर्ड एंटर करते हो तो वहां पर भी कई
बार क्या होता है आपको फ्रंट में बैनर
देखने को मिलता है कि सोन सो एफटीपी वर्जन
एंड सोन सो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम तो उससे आप
क्या कर सकते हो अगर ऐसी इंफॉर्मेशन आपको
देखने को को मिलती है तो आपके लिए उस
सर्विस को एक्सप्लोइट करने में हेल्प करती
है ये होती है आपकी बैनर ग्रैबिंग मतलब
किसी भी ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम किसी भी सर्विस
या उसके वर्जन के बारे में इंफॉर्मेशन
प्राप्त करना एक बैनर ग्रैबिंग का पार्ट
आता है बैनर ग्रैबिंग हम बार-बार यूज करते
हैं तो बैनर ग्रैबिंग का मतलब यही होता
है नहीं बैनर ग्रैबिंग का मतलब एन मैप
नहीं होता ब्रो बैनर ग्रैबिंग का मतलब
होता है कि जब भी आप सम कई बार आपने देखा
है कि कई कुछ लोग अपनी सर्विसेस के लिए एक
एडवर्टाइज चलाते हैं जब भी आप उसको ओपन
करते हो ना एक कंपनी नेम या उस सर्विस का
नेम बाय डिफॉल्ट आता है तो व एक बैनर होता
है लाइक दैट बैनर का मतलब अपने आप में
सिंपल मतलब है बैनर तो वही है बैनर
ग्रैबिंग कई बार आप क्या करते हो अगर आपने
के थ्र आप कन्फर करते तो वहां पर आपको एक
बैनर आता है आपने यस और नो तो सेलेक्ट
करते उससे पहले आता है कि वेलकम टू सोन सो
कंपनी या वेलकम टू सोन सो प्रोटोकॉल या
वेलकम टू सोन सो सर्विस एंड विद वर्जन तो
वह एक बैनर होता
है ओके अभी हम बात करते हैं कि
प्रैक्टिकली कैसे कर सकते नेट कट को ओके
तो सबसे पहले हम चलते हैं कि अभी हम ओ माय
गॉड अभी हमने अपनी मशीन को ऑन किया ही
नहीं है तो आई एम सॉरी फॉर दैट तो अभी एक
काम करते हैं हम ऑन कर लेते हैं मैं इसको
भूल गया ऑन करना मेरी मशीन को कि ओके हम
पैरेट ओस का यूज करेंगे तो इट विल टेक वन
से टू
मिनट ये है आपकी एक्चुअल स्ट्रेंथ दे आर
25 टू 26 स्टूडेंट्स
इस टॉपिक के टर्म में भी बैनर का मतलब सेम
ही
है आप नेटकट की हेल्प से ट्राई कर स मैं
अभी आपको प्रैक्टिकली दिखाऊंगा
32जीबी
रम देखिए दो हम टारगेट यूज करने वाले हैं
मैं अभी आपको शो कर देता हूं मैं विंडो
सर्वर 2008 यूज करने वाला यह देखो यह मेरा
टारगेट रहेगा विंडो सर्वर 2008 आ2 ओके तो
अभी अभी हम इसका आईपी एड्रेस चेक कर लेते
हैं कमांड प्रोमट एंड इसको मैं रिमोट
कनेक्शन क्रिएट हुआ है तो इफ
कॉन्फिडेंट तो इसका जो आईपी एड्रेस है
192.168 222 इसको हम यूज करने वाले हैं एज
ए टारगेट क्योंकि मैं ही प्रैक्टिकली आपको
शो करने वाला हूं तो ये हमारा टारगेट
रहेगा
168.0 222 ठीक है टिट ये आज का हमारा
टारगेट रहेगा तो अभी रिमोट रिमोट कनेक्शन
मैंने क्रिएट किया अपने विंड सर्वर 2008
के साथ ये एक वल्नरेबल विंडोज सर्वर है तो
इसको नो इशू अभी हम इसको परफॉर्म करके
दिखाऊंगा मैं आपके
सामने तो एक बार मशीन ऑन हो जाती
है तब तक आप मुझसे पूछ सकते हो किनका डाउट
था रिलेटेड टू प्रीवियस क्लास
येय ओके माय मशीन इज गुड फाइन ओके
ना तो अभी हम टर्मिनल ऑन करते हैं नाउ दिस
अवर टर्मिनल एंड नाउ यह
रहा कंट्रोल प्लस प्लस प्लस
यर टर्मिनल सबको दिखाई दे रहा
है क्लियर
है एवरीवन विजिबल या और जूम करना है
बताइए ओके तो नेटकट को यूज करने के लिए जो
कमांड होती है वो एनसी होती है जिसका नाम
क्या है एनसी और बाय डिफॉल्ट लगभग आपकी
मशीन में नक्स मशीन जो पैरेट ओस है या
काली
हान प पोट या ऐसे यूज कर सकते हो अब
डिस्क्रिप्शन में आपको पहले बताया हुआ है
जो मैंने आपको समझाया वही इसके
डिस्क्रिप्शन में है नेटकट इज अ सिंपल
यक्स यूटिलिटी यहां पर यक्स लिखा हुआ है
व्हिच रीड्स एंड राइट डाटा अक्रॉस नेटवर्क
कनेक्शंस यूजिंग टीसीपी और यूडीपी
प्रोटोकॉल जैसा मैंने आपको बताया कि यह
डाटा को रीड और राइट करने के लिए यूज किया
जाता है एक नेटवर्क यूटिलिटी है आपके
नेटवर्क के ऊपर टीजीपी और यूडीपी
प्रोटोकॉल का यूज करके मैंने आपको सिंपल
भाषा हमने अभी बताया था सिंपल वर्ड्स में
तो ये इसका डिस्क्रिप्शन है अब इसके बारे
में हम थोड़ा सा और जानते हैं देखिए यहां
पर कौन-कौन ऑप्शंस है हान सी ऑप्शन है
हाइन ई ऑप्शन है स्पेसिफाई फाइल नेम टू
एग्जीक्यूट आफ्टर कनेक्ट यूज विद कोजन सी
द हाइन सी ऑप्शन फॉर इनस फंक्शनल ओके हान
जी यूज कर सकते हो हाइन एच डिस्प्ले हेल्प
हान एल लिसन मोड एक जो हम नॉर्मल यूज करते
हैं हान एल मतलब आप सर्वर मोड में किसी भी
एक पर्टिकुलर पोर्ट के ऊपर लिसन कर सकते
हो हान n आप अगर चाहते हो कि आप नो डीएनएस
आप डीएनएस रेजोल नहीं करना चाहते तो उस
केस में आप हान ए का यूज कर सकते हो हाइन
ओ हैक्स डंप ट्रैफिक हाइन प पोर्ट मेंशन
कर सकते हो और हाइन अलाव यूडीपी
ब्रॉडकास्ट अभी एक और चीज है कि जो आपका
नेट कट है बाय डिफॉल्ट टीसीपी पोर्ट के
साथ कनेक्ट होता है बाय डिफॉल्ट टीसीपी
पोर्ट के साथ कनेक्ट होता है लेकिन हम
चाहे तो यूडीपी पोर्ट के साथ भी कनेक्ट कर
सकते हैं हान यू मेंशन करके अगर हम हाइन य
ऑप्शन का यूज करेंगे तोय टीसीपी पोर्ट की
बजाय यूडीपी पोर्ट के साथ कनेक्शन बनाएगा
तो ये
आपका ओके तो अभी हम इसको क्विट कर देते
हैं और इसको प्रैक्टिकली यूज करके दिखाते
हैं तो अभी फॉर एग्जांपल मेरा टारगेट आईपी
क्या है आज आपको बताया था तो एनसी हान
192.168 0
22 अभी मैं एग्जांपल मान के चलर कि हमने
एनम स्कैन किया और एन स्कैन करने के बाद
हमने रैंडम पोर्ट मिले जहां पर हमें हो
सकता जो सर्विस वाला पार्ट है वहां पर
हमें कुछ भी देखने को नहीं मिला तो फॉर
एग्जांपल अभी मैं हम नेट कट टारगेट आईपी
देन उसके बाद पोर्ट 80 में करता हूं यहां
पर पोर्ट 80 और सिंपली हिट एंटर करता हूं
मैं आपको दिखाता हूं यह रहा हिट एंटर किया
यहां पर आप कुछ भी देखने को नहीं मिल रहा
इसका एक कारण है
क्योंकि क्योंकि यहां पर आपने ऑप्शंस
मेंशन नहीं कि एक तो हाइ फन व वर्बोस मोड
ना ही आपने फिर यहां पर मेंशन किया कि
हाइन एन मतलब अभी क्या कर बाय डिफॉल्ट यह
क्या कर रहा है डीएनएस रेजोल्यूशन करेगा
इसके लिए अभी डीएनएस तो है नहीं क्योंकि
डोमेन सय सॉरी हां डोमेन नेम तो है ही
नहीं डोमेन तो है ही नहीं तो हम उसको क्या
कर सकते हैं स्टॉप कर सकते कंट्रोल सी तो
मैं क्या करता हूं एनसी हाइन ए उसके बाद
वी हाइन व ओके साथ के साथ व वर्बोस मोड
देन
192 168 ये बैनर ग्रैबिंग कर रहा है अभी
ये इसका एक फीचर है अभ इसका काम नहीं है
लेकिन ये इस के अंदर एक फीचर प्रोवाइड
किया कि अगर किसी भी ओपन पोर्ट्स के लिए
बैनर प्रोवाइड किया गया है तो वो बैनर
ग्रैबिंग आपको बैनर ग्रैब करके उस बैनर को
प्रिंट करके दिखा दिया कि ओके व्हाट टाइप
ऑफ इंफॉर्मेशन यू आर गेटिंग जीरो डॉट 222
उसके बाद पोर्ट 80 देखिए हिट एंटर ये रहा
अभी ये देखो यहां पर अननोन मैं कुछ नहीं
है लेकिन आईपी एड्रेस पोर्ट 80 एचटीटीपी
और ओपन है यहां पर हमें क्या चीज पता चल
गई पोर्ट 8 तो हमने मेंशन किया था लेकिन
एटीटीपी प्रोटोकॉल का यूज कर रहा है लेकिन
ओपन है अभी यहां पर कुछ भी रैंडम हम टाइप
करते हैं फॉर एग्जांपल मैंने क्या किया
मैं मान रहा हूं कि एक विंडो मशीन है तो
डीआई आर टाइप किया हिट एंटर
देखो बैड रिक्वेस्ट है लेकिन यहां पर हमें
क्या मिला माइक्रोसॉफ्ट
एचटीटीपी एपीआई
2.0 और यह कनेक्शन यह क्या बैड रिक्वेस्ट
थी तो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है क्योंकि वैलिड
रिक्वेस्ट नहीं थी लेकिन इसने कनेक्शन बना
लिया था पोर्ट ए के साथ ओके बट यह क्या है
वहां पर कुछ भी सेल कन्फर नहीं था या कुछ
कन्फर नहीं था क्योंकि यह सिर्फ कनेक्शन
एब्लिश कर रहा है उसके साथ ओके तो यहां पर
इसको ये इंफॉर्मेशन देखने फॉर एग्जांपल
मैं पोट 21 पर ट्राई करता हूं अभी आपके
सामने फॉर एग्जांपल पोर्ट 21 ट्राई करता
हूं यह देखिए पोर्ट 21 पर आपको देखने को
क्या मिल रहा है हिट एंटर
देखिए एफटीपी ओपन माइक्रोसॉफ्ट एफटीपी
सर्विस मतलब माइक्रोसॉफ्ट का यूज किया जा
रहा है अभी रैंडम कुछ भी मैं एंटर करूंगा
देखिए अभी
मतलब कनेक्ट हो गया लेकिन अभी ऑथेंटिकेटेड
नहीं है बट अगर यहां पर जो बैनर अवेलेबल
था यह आपके सामने इसने इफर्म प्रोवाइड कर
दिया कंट्रोल सी करता हूं अभी के लिए मैं
इसको अगर पोर्ट 22 ट्राई करता हूं देखो
पोर्ट 22 अभी देखो यह देखो 198 2 22 एसएसए
2.0 ओपन एसएसए 7.1 दिस इज एग्जैक्ट
एग्जांपल ऑफ योर बैनर ग्रबिंग येय एक बैनर
है जैसे आपको कंफर्म हो गया एसएसएस वर्जन
2.0 यूज किया जा रहा है व भी कौन सा अपन
एसएसए 7.1 एजेक्ट वर्जन के साथ ओके एवरीवन
क्लियर पता चल गया कि बनर ग्रबिंग कैसे की
जाती है नेटकट की हेल्प से बताइए मुझे चैट
में बताओ
बताओ जल्दी से चैट में बताइए अभी मैं इसको
क्लोज कर देता हूं कंट्रोल सी
ओके तो ये एक बैनर ग्रबिंग का परफेक्ट
एग्जांपल और अभी हम जो यूज कर रहे हैं ना
अभी हम क्लाइंट मोड यूज कर रहे अभी हम
क्या कर रहे हैं क्लाइंट मोड यूज कर रहे
हैं जैसे कि फॉर एग्जांपल और भी एग्जांपल
दिखाता हूं पोर्ट 139 दिखाता हूं चलो
पोर्ट
139 हिट एंटर नेट बायोस एसस डीआई आर करते
हैं तो ऑटोमेटिक कट हो गया क्योंकि ये
इसके लिए है नहीं अभी देखो
445 हिट एंटर माइक्रोसॉफ्ट डीएस ओपन
क्योंकि 445 क्या एसएमबी प्रोटोकॉल है तो
कंट्रोल सी कर दिया हमने वैसे अगर कुछ भी
रैंडम ट्राई करोगे तो ऑटोमेटिक बंद हो
जाएगा
आप यूज कर सकते हो आपने राकेश मैंने लास्ट
क्लास में एक बार मेटा स्टेबल 3 आपको
बताया था कि कैसे कंफिल करना
है अगर वह आप कन्फर कर रखा लब सेटअप किया
तो आप उस पर प्रैक्टिस कर सकते हो या मेटा
स्टेबल टू को डाउनलोड करो और उस पर
प्रैक्टिस कर सकते हो खुद से या खुद आप
अपनी मशीन में एक काम करो कि वर्चुअल
बॉक्स में या वीएम वेयर में एक और दूसरी
विंडोज मशीन और ऐड कर लो और उस पर
प्रैक्टिस कर सकते
हो हाइड्रा क्लास हो गई यार कब की हो गई
हाइड्रा की क्लास क्लास में नहीं आओगे तो
कैसे पता चलेगा ओके तो इस तरीके से आप
क्या कर सकते हो नेट नेट कट का क्लाइंट
मोड यूज कर सकते हो अभी मैं आपको बताता
हूं अभी मैं आपको सिखाता हूं एक और
टेक्निक कि हम इसको सर्वर मोड में कैसे
यूज कर सकते हैं कि हम लिसन कैसे कर सकते
किसी पर्टिकुलर पोर्ट के लिए तो उसके लिए
मुझे क्या करना चाहिए क्या करना पड़ेगा
मुझे क्लाइंट और सर्वर दोनों चाहिए होंगे
और क्लाइंट और सर्वर के लिए मैंने आपको
दिखाया था एक तो मेरे
का ट्रांसफर करना है तो कैसे करोगे वो
आपको मैं से अपकमिंग क्लास में सिखाऊंगा
कि अगर मुझे अपने टारगेट के ऊपर कोई फाइल
ट्रांसफर करनी है टारगेट सिस्टम के ऊपर तो
मैं कैसे कर सकता हूं वह भी मैं आपको
सिखाऊंगा लेकिन अभी मुझे बताइए अगर मुझे
अभी बाय डिफॉल्ट माइक्रोसॉफ्ट विंडोज के
अंदर नेट कट नहीं आती है अभी इसके अंदर
अवेलेबल है क्योंकि मैंने ट्रांसफर किया
हुआ य र एनसी नाम से एनसीड लेकिन अगर मुझे
इसके अंदर ट्रांसफर करना तो कैसे कर सकते
हैं क्योंकि देखिए
देखिए यहां
पर अभी कोई भी लिनक्स मशीन है खास कर की
जो अपनी पेन टेस्टिंग लिन मशीन है तो अभी
हम एक बार क्लियर कर देते हैं इसको य और
इसको मैं ऊपर ले चलता
हूं यहा तो अगर आप करोगे एल एस हाइन एल
उसके बाद स्ल यूएस आर
शेयर और
विंडोज विंडोज रिसोर्सेस य पैरेट ओस के
लिए है लेकिन काली में जाओगे तो आप
विंडोज के बाद टैप करोगे तो वहां पर ओपन
हो जाएगा उसके बाद यहां पर क्या है हिट
एंटर देख यहां पर अवेलेबल है एन कट नेट कट
की एग्जीक्यूटेबल फाइल अवेलेबल है पावर कट
की एग्जीक्यूटेबल फाइल पावर स् पलट की
एचडीबी की और एसडी यह सारी क्या है फाइल्स
अवेलेबल है मुझे नेट कट फाइल ट्रांसफर
करनी है तो मैं क्या करूंगा सीधी सीधी सी
बात है सीडी करूंगा देन यह रहा मैं इसी पर
सीडी करता
हूं चेंज डायरेक्टरी उसके बाद फिड एन
कैट अभी एल एस यह क्या नेट कट्स तो हम
डायरेक्टली क्या करेंगे क्योंकि सेम
नेटवर्क में है तो हम बाय डिफॉल्ट पाइथन
अवेलेबल होते है हम पाइथन सर्वर स्टार्ट
करेंगे
python3
सवर यहां पर उसके बाद पोर्ट कौन सा हम यूज
करने वाले हैं पोर्ट 80 और हिट एंटर कर
दिया तो यहां पर पाइथन सर्वर स्टार्ट हो
गया और अभी हम क्या कर सकते हैं हमारा
टारगेट मशीन है ये टारगेट मशीन के अंदर भी
ब्राउजर नहीं है तो हम क्या कर सकते हैं
डायरेक्टली गो टू अ कमांड प्रोमट अभी
कमांड प्रोमट प जाएंगे और अभी क्या है कि
यहां पर आपको शायद कुछ ना देखने को मिले
क्योंकि इसको जूम नहीं कर सकता इसको मैं
जूम नहीं कर
सकता दिस इज
डिसएडवांटेज ये रहा मैं इसको एक बार क्लोज
कर देता हूं फिर से ओपन करता हूं यह
रहा नो
देखिए फंट ओके
मीडियम ओके फंट लेते हैं हम
12 उसके बाद ले आउट
विड हाइट विड हाइट
लेपटॉप कलर नहीं चाहिए ऑप्शन था हो गया
ओके करते हम इसको देखते हैं यह रहा ओके
नाउ इ विजिबल सबको दिखाई दे रहा
है ओके अभी हम यहां पर क्या कर सकते हैं
पाइथन सर्वर रनिंग है तो विंडोज के अंदर
एक कमांड होती है अभी जब विंडोज के बारे
में पढ़ेंगे तो मैं आपको विंडोज की बेसिक
कमांड के बारे में इंफॉर्मेशन प्रोवाइड
करूंगा लेकिन अभी के लिए आपको दिखा देता
हूं सर्ट यूटिलमन
सर्ट यूट हाइन आप यूज कर सकते क् मार्क य
देखो यह इसकी विंडोज की कमांड है तो अभी
इसको आप जूम कर सकते हो वैसे यह र विंडोज
कमांड है तो कमांड कैसे यूज करूंगा मैं
सर्ट यूट यह कमांड ध्यान से देख लेना अभी
के लिए अदर वाइज मैं आपको बताऊंगा
हाइन यूआरएल सी ए हान यरल कैचे हाइन फाइल
उसके बाद
एचटीटीपी उसका आईपी एड्रेस मेरा क्या है
192.168
0 डट अभी मैं क्या करना हो 160 है उसका
आईपी एड्रेस फाइल नेम क्या है मेरा अगर आप
देखोगे तो यह फाइल नेम है यहां पर कौन सा
n कट n
कट तो n
कट
एडसी ओके उसके बाद अभी मैं कहां पर सेव
करना चाहता हूं इसको इसको सेव करना चाहता
हूं मैं डेस्कटॉप के अंदर नहीं अभी फॉर
एग्जांपल मुझे सबसे पहले डेस्कटॉप पर
शिफ्ट करना था लेकिन अभी मैं इसको यहीं पर
सेव करना चाहता हूं कि एन कट ड कहां पर
इसी एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर के होम अकाउंट के अंदर
अदर वाइज मैं डेस्कटॉप पर भी लेके आ सकता
हूं और ट एंटर करना आपको मैं फिर से बता
देता हूं सर्ट यूट हाइन यूआरएल कैच हान एफ
उसके बाद आपका यूआरएल प्रॉपर आपका
एचटीटीपी है एटीटीपी है देन नेट n कट फुल
उसके बाद एन कट यह आपको जिस नाम से सेव
करना है इट एंटर कर दिया अभी हमने क्या कर
दिया एंटर कर दिया यहां पर इट विल टेक
टाइम बट यहां पर आपकी फाइल डाउनलोड हो
जाएगी देखो ऑनलाइन यूरल कैच कमांड
कंप्लीटेड सक्सेसफुली और यहां पर देखोगे
तो ट्रांसफर भी हो गया 200 ओके था तो अभी
इसको हम बंद कर देते हैं इट्स ओके और यहां
पर भी कनेक्शन अभी इसको हम क्लोज कर देते
हैं अभी के लिए अभी क्लोज नहीं करेंगे
वैसे अभी मैं डेस्कटॉप प चलता हूं पहले
क्योंकि मेरे पास पहले से फाइल है सीडी
डेस्कटॉप सीडी डेस्कटॉप हिट एंटर और अगर
डीआई आर करोगे तो यहां पर अवेलेबल आपकी
कौन सी एनसीड एक्सी एनसीड
एक्सी तो अभी हम क्या करने वाले इसको यूज
करेंगे अभी चेक करने के लिए चेक करें किय
चल रहा नहीं तो
एनसीड और हाइन एच यूज करते हैं हम हान एच
यह देखो ट वर्किंग ये इसकी हेल्प फाइल ओपन
होगी य देखो ये इसकी हेल्प फाइल ओपन हो गई
तो अभी के लिए मैं क्या करूंगा अभी के लिए
हम क्या करने वाले हैं फिर अभी मैं लिनर
ऑन करता हूं यह क्लाइंट है यहां पर लिनर
है मेरा देखो यहां पर लिनर तो लिनर ऑन
करने के लिए मैं क्या करूंगा तो नेट कट
हाइ फन यूज करेंगे हम हाइ फन एन नो डीएनएस
रेजोल्यूशन एल फॉर लिसनिंग उसके
बाद नहीं नो डीएनएस के लिए यज कर एल फॉर
लिसनिंग एलवी वर्बोस प फ पोर्ट कौन से
पोर्ट पर लिसन करने वाले हम टूथ 4 पोर्ट
पर हम क्या करेंगे लिसन करेंगे क्योंकि य
सर्वर मोड है य पर मैं लिसन कर रहा हूं
देन उसके बाद गो टू योर विंडोज मशीन
एनसीड उसके बाद हाइन क्या यूज करोगे आप
हान ए और व हान एवी उसके बाद टारगेट आईपी
एड्रेस
192.168
0160 यह आपका टारगेट आईपी एड्रेस है और
उसके बाद कौन से पोर्ट नंबर पर टूथ 4 के
ऊपर और हिट एंटर
देखिए कनेक्टेड और यहां पर आपको अभी देखना
रिवर्स सेल मिल जाएगा देखो यहां पर आपको
रिवर्स सेल मिलेगा अभी वेट अभी यहां पर
क्या है कनेक्टेड टू
192.16 1660 12234 और अभी यहां पर हमें
रिवर्स सेल मिलेगा
वेट ओके हां यह कनेक्शन क्रिएट हो गया अभी
यहां पर हम अगर डीआई आर करेंगे देखो अभी
कुछ नहीं है कुछ भी नहीं अभी ओनली कनेक्शन
क्रिएट हुआ है यहां पर ओनली कनेक्शन
क्रिएट हो गया सर्वर और क्लाइंट का
स्पोर्ट के साथ कनेक्शन क्रिएट हो गया अभी
यहां पर उसका सेल कैसे मिलेगा और बाइन सेल
और रिवर्स सेल की जो कहानी मैं आपको आगे
बताऊंगा तो या सब कुछ यहां तक सबको समझ
में आ
गया हां फिजिकल मशीन में आप ट्राई कर सकते
हैं इसको सेम नेटवर्क में होने
चाहिए सेम नेटवर्क के अंदर होने चाहिए तो
आप इसको ट्राई कर सकते हो
हो
ओके यहां तक सबको क्लियर
है अखिलेश राव क्या हुआ क्या समझ में नहीं
आया आपको
बताइए बताइए बताइए बताइए अभी हम बाइ एंड
सेल और रिवर्स सेल के बारे में पढ़ेंगे
लेकिन यह जो कांसेप्ट था यह फंडामेंटल
कांसेप्ट आपका नेटकट का मैंने आपको
एक्सप्लेन कर दिया अभी मैं कंट्रोल सी कर
देता हूं क्लोज और यहां से भी इसको मैं
क्या करता हूं क्लोज हो गया
ये मैं आपको क्या करा रहा हूं मैं आपको
सिखा रहा हूं कि नेट कट को हम कैसे यूज कर
सकते
हैं क्लाइंट मोड में और सर्वर मोड में अभी
मैंने आपको क्या किया था कि जो मेरा पैरेट
ओस था पैरेट पैरेट ओस को मैं क्लाइंट
सर्वर मोड में यूज कर रहा था मतलब मैं
पोर्ट नंबर यहां पर देखो एनसी नेट कट हान
n का मतलब मैं डीएनएस यूज नहीं करना चाहता
उसके बाद में हर एक यहां पर कोई आईपी
मेंशन नहीं किया मैंने यहां पर ओके वी
वबोस प पोर्ट नंबर 1 2 3 4 प मैं क्या कर
रहा हूं लिसन कर रहा हूं एक सर्वर हूं मैं
यहां पर वेट कर रहा हूं कि मुझसे कोई भी
क्लाइंट कनेक्ट हो और यहां पर मैंने क्या
किया कि यहां नेट कट जो यूटिलिटी थी यहां
पर मैं उसको एज ए क्लाइंट यूज कर रहा हूं
मैं पोर्ट नंबर टूथ से क्या कर रहा हूं
अपना कनेक्शन एब्लिश कर रहा हूं तो मैंने
वही सिंपल काम किया कि विंडो को और अपने
लिनक्स मशीन को एक कनेक्शन प्रोवाइड किया
पोर्ट के थ्रू हमने क्या कर दिया उसको
जोड़ दिया बस इतना सिखाया है और अब यह
कहां पर काम आएगा कैसे हेल्पफुल होगा
हमारे लिए मैं आपको अभी कुछ स्लाइड के
थ्रू आपको बताऊंगा
हा नेट कैट दोनों पर होना
चाहिए नेट कट आपके विंडो पर भी होना चाहिए
और आपके लिनक्स प भी होना चाहिए ट्रांसफर
कैसे करना मैंने आपको बता दिया मैंने सबसे
पहले क्या किया कि बाय डिफॉल्ट नेट नेट कट
की ए फाइल्स है वो आपकी अवेलेबल होती है
यहां पर देखो पैरेट के केस में यहां पर
अवेलेबल य देखो यह उसका पाथ है और यहां पर
यह उसकी एग्जीक्यूटेबल फाइल अवेलेबल से
नेटकट की इसको मैंने पाइथन सर्वर मैंने
अपनी मशीन पर पाइथन सर्वर रन किया और उससे
क्या किया विंडो मशीन के ऊपर डाउनलोड कर
लिया उस सर्वर की हेल्प से उस फाइल को
ट्रांसफर कर लिया देन उस फाइल को मैं यूज
कर रहा हूं एज ए क्लाइंट और यहां पर एज
सर्वर नाउ क्लियर
नाउ एवरीवन
क्लियर अभी हम आपको समझाता हूं आगे और भी
यह
रहा ना अी
देखो कि ट इज हाउ वी कैन सेट अप लिनर और
हमने देखा कि हम क्लाइंट को लिनर से कैसे
कनेक्ट कर सकते हैं अभी प्रैक्टिकली आपको
दिखाया वई दिस इ सो इंपोर्टेंट
अभी यह इंपॉर्टेंट क्यों है यह आपको
दिखाता हूं मैं व्हाई दिस इज सो
इंपोर्टेंट इट विल मेक मच मोर सेंस व्हेन
वी एक्सप्लोर हाउ टू यूज नेट कट यूटिलिटी
टू ऑब्टेन ए बाइंडर रिवर्स सेल और यह आपको
अच्छे से तब समझ में आएगा जब मैं आपको
सिखाऊंगा कि बाइंडर्स सेल क्या होते हैं
और नेट कैट का कैसे यूज किया जाता है
बाइंडर्स सेल के केस में और क्यों
इंपॉर्टेंट है नेट कट के बारे में समझना
यह भी आपको पता चल जाएगा तो अभी हम
नेक्स्ट स्लाइड में चलते हैं कि बाइंडेड
होता क्या है तो सबसे पहले इस सेक्शन में
हम सीखने वाले कि बाइंडेड होते क्या हैं
हम नेटकट की हेल्प नेटकट की हेल्प से बाइन
सेल को कैसे सेटअप कर सकते हैं एंड लास्ट
थिंग कि वी वी आर गोइंग टू अंडरस्टैंड
व्हाई रिवर्स सेल आर प्रेफर्ड ओवर बाइन
सेल जो रिवर्स सेल्स हैं वह बाइन सेल से
ज्यादा बेटर क्यों है क्यों प्रेफर
प्रेफरेंस ज्यादा दिए जाती है कि होके
हमेशा हर कोई पेंटेस्ट आपको बोलेगा कि
रिवर्स सेल का यूज करो रदर देन बाइंडर
व्हाट इज द डिफरेंस बिटवीन रिवर्स सेल एंड
बाइन सेल वई रिवर्स सेल आर मच बेटर देन
बाइन सेल यह सारे सवालों के जवाब मैं आपको
अभी क्लास में प्रोवाइड
करूंगा आपको
बताऊंगा अभी मैं आपको बताऊंगा ये देखो ना
बाइड सेल क्या होता है बाइड सेल इज ए टाइप
ऑफ रिमोट सेल बाइड सेल एक रिमोट सेल है एक
प्रकार का रिमोट सेल है वेर अटैकर्स
कनेक्ट डायरेक्टली टू ए लिनर ऑन द टारगेट
सिस्टम कंसीक्वेंटली अलांग फॉर
एग्जीक्यूशन ऑफ कमांड्स ऑन द टारगेट
सिस्टम बेसिकली आई कैन से दैट बांड सेल एक
रिमोट सेल है जिस के जिसमें क्या होता है
जो आपके अटैकर्स है पेंटेस्टर्स है या
एथिकल हैकर्स हैं वो डायरेक्टली उस लिस्नर
के साथ क्या करते हैं कनेक्शन एस्टेब्लिश
करते हैं जो टारगेट सिस्टम है और जिससे वह
क्या कर सकते हैं अपनी कमांड रन कर सकते
हैं उस सिस्टम के
ऊपर नहीं समझ में आया आपको फिर से बताता
हूं कि ये एक रिमोट सेल है बांड सेल एक
प्रकार का रिमोट सेल है और जो आपके
अटैकर्स है या जो एथिकल हैकर्स हैं वो
आपके टारगेट सिस्टम के साथ डायरेक्टली
कनेक्शन एस्टेब्लिश करके अपनी कमांड रन
करते
हैं यह होता है आपका बाइंडर अब सेल क्या
होता है सेल इज ए प्रोग्राम और यूटिलिटी
दैट अलाउ यू टू एग्जीक्यूट कमांड्स ऑन एन
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम और ए सेल अभी सेल एक ऐसा
प्रोग्राम एक ऐसी यूटिलिटी होती है जिसके
थ्रू आप किसी भी ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम या
सिस्टम के ऊपर अपनी कमांड रन कर सकते हो
या अपने सिस्टम के साथ कम्युनिकेट कर सकते
हो
वाया वाया
सील आई ओके कमांड लाइन इंटरफेस एंड ए नेट
कट लिनर कैन बी सेट अप टू एग्जीक्यूट ए
स्पेसिफिक एग्जीक्यूटेबल लाइक
सीएडीसी और स्ल बिन बस व्हेन ए क्लाइंट
कनेक्ट टू द लिनर अभी आप क्या करते हो कि
बाइन सेल के केस में नेट कट लिनर को सेट
अप करते हो किसके ऊपर टारगेट सिस्टम के
ऊपर और एक स्पेसिफिक टास्क परफॉर्म करने
के लिए कि जब भी कोई क्लाइंट मेरे टारगेट
जब भी कोई क्लाइंट नेटकट लिनर से कनेक्ट
हो तो यह एग्जीक्यूटेबल फाइल या यह बाइनरी
फाइल रन होनी चाहिए जैसे केलिए कमांड डई
आप कमांड प्रोमट प्रोवाइड करना चाहते हो
लेस के केस में आप बेस्ट सेल प्रोवाइड
करना चाहते हो ओके आपको क्या करना चाहिए
टारगेट टारगेट से आपको चाहिए क्या टारगेट
से आपको चाहिए उसका सेल चाहिए सेल एक्सेस
चाहिए ठीक है सीआई एक्सेस चाहिए अब विंडोज
के केस में आपको कमांड प्रोमट चाहिए और
लिनक्स के केस में आपको बेस्ट सेल चाहिए
या सेल चाहिए ओनली आपको तो ये दोनों केस
में आप क्या करोगे कि नेट कट लिनर को सेट
अप करोगे और जब और ऐसा सेट अप करोगे कि
जैसे ही आप कनेक्शन क्रिएट करोगे तो आपको
उसका कमांड प्रंट मिले या आपका बेस्ट सेल
मिले नस के केस में ये कैसे होता है मैं
आपको दिखाऊंगा तो अभी मैं बताता हूं इन
ऑर्डर टू ऑब्टेन ए माइंड सेल ए नेट कट
लिनर मस्ट बी कंफर्ड ऑन द ट सिस्टम अगर
आपको बाइंडर चाहिए टारगेट सिस्टम से तो उस
केस में आपका जो नेट कैट लिनर कंफिल होना
चाहिए आपके टारगेट के ऊपर ओके यह पहली
कंडीशन है तो फॉर एग्जांपल यहां पर क्या
है हियर नेटकट लिनर इ कन्फर टू एग्जीक्यूट
ए सेल डिपेंडिंग ऑन द ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
यहां पर क्या है कि हमने नेटकट लिनर को
कंफिट किया हुआ है कि जब भी कोई क्लाइंट
कनेक्ट होगा इस टारगेट ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के
साथ वाया नेट कट लिनर या इस लिनर पे तो
उसको क्या करर है सेल एक्सेस मिल जाएगा और
ये डिपेंड करता है आपके ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
के ऊपर कि आप कमांड प्रोमट प्रोवाइड करते
हो या आप बेस्ट सेल प्रोवाइड करते हो वंस
ट नेट कट लिनर स्टार्ट सेट अप एंड कंफिट
टू एग्जीक्यूट ए सेल देन एनी नेटकट
क्लाइंट कैन कनेक्ट टू द लिनर विल
प्रोवाइडेड विद रिमोट कमांड प्रोमट सेशन
ओके हमने यहां पर ऐसे कंफिल किया है कि
जैसे कनेक्ट होगे तो आपको
रिमोट कमांड प्रम सेशन मिलेगा गेटिंग माय
पॉइंट कि बाइन सेल होता क्या है और बाइन
सेल के लिए आप की क्या कंडीशन है कि आपका
नेट कट लिनर कंफिल होना चाहिए एक
स्पेसिफिक बाइनरी फाइल को एग्जीक्यूट करने
के
लिए बताइए
बाइ एंड सेल के बारे में अभी तक क्लियर है
कुछ चीजें प्रैक्टिकली मैं आपको अभी
बताऊंगा कि प्रैक्टिकली कैसे काम करता
है अगर वह किसी दूसरी सिटी में है तो उस
केस में पहली बात तो वहां पर बाइड सेल यूज
नहीं करते हम रिवर्स सेल यूज करते हैं और
उस केस में हम कमांड एंड कंट्रोल सर्वर का
यूज करते हैं और कमांड एंड कंट्रोल सर्वर
के थ्रू कोई भी अटैकर अटैक करता है और और
वह एक टेक्निक है आपकी क्लाइंट साइड अटैक
सोशल इंजीनियरिंग के थ्रू ही अगर आपका जो
अटैक है अटैक आप रियलिस्टिक अटैक परफॉर्म
कर रहे हो और अगर आपके जो सर्वर्स हैं या
आपके टारगेट ऑर्गेनाइजेशन है अगर वह
वेलेबल नहीं है आपको उसके अंदर कोई
एक्सप्लोइटेशन नहीं मिल रहा है या पब्लिक
फेसिंग सर्वर्स अवेलेबल नहीं है उस केस
में आप ट्राई कर करते हो क्लाइंट सेड अटैक
दैट इज कॉल्ड सोशल इंजीनियरिंग और आप
कन्वेंस करते हो एंप्लॉई को या कस्टमर को
कि वह आपकी उस फाइल पर क्लिक करे और जैसे
क्लिक करेगा आपको वहां से रिवर्स सेल मिल
जाएगा या आई विल एक्सप्लेन
ओके तो अभी देखो कि आप लोगों का सवाल है
अभी मेनी टाइम्स यू हियर द रिवर्स सेल आर
मच बेटर देन बाइन सेल कि बहुत बार आपने
सुना होगा कि जो रिवर्स सेल्स है मच मच
बेटर देन बाइन सेल कि आपको बांड सेल ना
यूज करके रिवर्स सेल यूज करना चाहिए क्यों
उसके कुछ कारण है तो व्हाट इज द प्रॉब्लम
फ्रॉम द पर्सपेक्टिव ऑफ एन अटैकर अगर मैं
एक अटैकर्स की तरह सोच के आपको बताऊं कि
मैं एक अटैकर हूं और उसके पर्सपेक्टिव से
आपको बताऊं तो दो रीजंस है एक्चुअली वी
नीड टू सेट अप ए नेटकट लिनर ऑन द टारगेट
सिस्टम सबको समझ में आ गया होगा अगर मुझे
बाइंडेड क्रिएट करना है तो मुझे टारगेट के
ऊपर नेट कट लिनर को सेट अप करना होगा और
हाउ डू वी डू दिस इफ वी डोंट इवन हैव
एक्सेस टू द टारगेट सिस्टम आप लोगों का
सेम सवाल में आंसर करने जा रहा हूं ये अगर
मेरे पास टारगेट सिस्टम का एक्सेस ही नहीं
है तो मैं नेटकट लिनर कैसे सेटअप करूंगा
यह एक पोटेंशियल इशू है सेकंड इशू क्या है
नेटवर्क सिक्योरिटी इशू है क्योंकि मोस्ट
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम लाइक विंडोज या नक्
अब सबसे बड़ी हेडेक ये है फर्स्ट हेडेक
आपने सॉल्व कैसे ना कैसे कर भी ली सेकंड
हेडेक क्या है आपकी कि जितना भी इनकमिंग
इन बाउंड ट्रैफिक जो इनकमिंग ट्रैफिक होता
है मोस्टली किसी भी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन में उसको
ज्यादा से ज्यादा हर एक फायर वाल आईडीएस
आईपीएस या सिक्योरिटी सोल्यूशन के द्वारा
क्या किया जाता है फिल्टर किया जाता है या
खास कर के नेटकट यूटिलिटी वाले ट्रैफिक को
तो ब्लॉक कर दिया जाता है यह दो बड़े रीजन
है बाइंडर यूज ना करने के इन दो कारणों से
हम बाइड सेल कभी भी रिकमेंड नहीं करते
हमेशा रिकमेंड क्या करते हैं रिवर्स सेल
ओके क्लियर कि वई रिवर्स सेल आर मच मच
बेटर देन बाइन
सेल
क्लियर
ओके तो दिस इज वयर द होल आइडिया ऑफ रिव
सेल कम्स इन टू प्ले रिवर्स सेल में क्या
होता है टारगेट कनेक्ट टू द अटैकर मशीन ऑन
नेट कट लिनर और द रीजन और द रीजन फॉर दैट
आउटगोइंग ट्रैफिक फ्रॉम द सिस्टम इज रियली
ब्लॉक्ड बाय द सिक्योरिटी सोल्यूशन अभी
रिवर्स सेल यूज करने का कारण यह है कि जो
टारगेट सिस्टम है वो आपके सिस्टम से क्या
करता है कनेक्ट करता है आप उसको कनेक्ट
नहीं कर रहे वोह आपके सिस्टम से कनेक्ट कर
रहा है और जनरली जो ऑर्गेनाइजेशन के अंदर
जो आउटगोइंग ट्रैफिक होता है उसको
ज्यादातर मॉनिटर नहीं किया जाता दैट इज द
मेन रीजन कि रिवर्स सेल इज मोर फोकस्ड रदर
देन बाइन
सेल ओके यहां तक समझ में आया सबको क्लियर
है बताइए अभी हम इसका प्रैक्टिकली
देखेंगे बाइन सेल का बाय सेन का
प्रैक्टिकली देखेंगे तो रिवर्स सेल के
बारे में थोड़ी सी इंफॉर्मेशन लेंगे का भी
प्रैक्टिकल देखेंगे ओके और आपको मैं
रिवर्स सेल की चीट शट प्रोवाइड करूंगा
बेस्ट चीट शट जहां से आप खुद के रिवर्स
सेल देख सकते हो पेलोड लेटर टू और उनको
फिर आप अपने हिसाब से यूज कर सकते
हो ओके आर यू रेडी
गाइस एक्शन के लिए रेडी
हो ओके रिमोट कनेक्शन टूट गया नो
इशू अगेन फिर से हम क्रिएट कर लेंगे हमारे
हाथ में है ना ओके इट्स ओके ओके ओके
ना ओके तो उसके लिए हम क्लाइंट उसको यूज
करेंगे तो बाइ एंड सेल्ट क्रिएट करने के
लिए सबसे पहले मैं आपको दिखाता हूं कि
विंडोज से हम बांड सेल्ट कैसे क्रिएट कर
सकते हैं विंडोज से विंडोज के ऊपर हम क्या
करेंगे एक लिनर सेटअप करेंगे तो यह हमारा
नेटकट की एग्जीक्यूटेबल फाइल अवेलेबल है
अभी विंडो के ऊपर मैं आपको दिखा रहा हूं
तो यह मेरा यह रहा देखो कमांड प्रोमट है
और कमांड प्रोमट में आपको दिखाता हूं
एनसीड ई एक्ससी उसके बाद हाइ फन हम यूज
करेंगे हाइ फन
एनवी
एल प हाइन एनवी एल प अब सर्वर सेटअप कर
रहे हैं यहां पर हाइन एन मतलब नो डीएनएस
वी वर्बोस एल फॉर लिसनिंग पोर्ट नंबर कौन
सा टूथ 4 दिस इज आवर पोर्ट नंबर देन एक और
ऑप्शन यूज करेंगे हाइन ई हाइन ई का मतलब
हम वो फाइल मेंशन करेंगे जैसे ही हमारा जो
नेटकट क्लाइंट है इसके साथ कनेक्शन बनाएगा
जैसे इसके साथ कनेक्ट होगा तो उसको कौन सी
फाइल का एक्सेस मिले तो हम कैसे कर सकते
हैं तो सीएमडी
डसी सीएमडी
डटसी ओके
सीएडीसी और उससे पहले हमें क्या करना
पड़ेगा गो टू
योर पैरेट ओस और यहां पर हमें क्या करना
पड़ेगा ओके इसको बाद में यूज करेंगे यह
कनेक्शन है और यहां पर हम क हिट एंटर यहां
पर लिसनिंग है यहां पर क्या आपकी लिसनिंग
है पोर्ट टूथ पर कोई भी कनेक्ट करेगा इससे
तो यहां पर क्या हो जाएगा ये कनेक्ट कर
लेगा नाउ अभी हम क्या करते हैं यहां पर
एनसी हाइन एवी उसके बाद टारगेट आई प क्या
192.168 दो उसके बाद पोर्ट नंबर क्या है
टूथ 4 और हिट एंटर और लेट्स बूम ना
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वर्जन 6.1 सोन सो एंड वी गट
द सेल एक्सेस कमांड प्रम जैसे की हु एम
आई एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर और अगर मैं गेट यू आईडी
करता हूं गेट यू आईडी यूजर आईडी य देखो
अभी इसमें गेट यू आईडी काम नहीं करेगा
प्रि देखना चाहता हूं देखो हु एम आई उसके
बाद
प्रिविलेज यह देखो
ओके
प्रीविस ओ माय गड
अभी हो एम
आई यह देखो यह सारे प्रिविलेज देख पा रहे
हो देखो अगर मैं इसको व कर देता हूं यह
रहा ज ल आर द प्रिविलेज देख डिसेबल डिसेबल
य इसके प्रिविलेज है नाउ अगर हम और भी
फाइल जैसे डीई करते देखो
डीआई आर डेस्कटॉप सीडी
डेस्कटॉप व्हाट एवर आई वांट मैं सब कुछ कर
सकता हूं सीडी डेस्कटॉप डीआई आर पूरा
विंडो टर्मिनल देखो य
एनसीड एवरीवन क्लियर सबको समझ में आया कि
यहां
पर हमने विंडो का एक्सेस ले लिया लिनेक्स
के थ्रू बांड सेल ये एक बाइंडर है फॉर
एग्जांपल अभी मैं आपको अगर इसके थ्रू
समझाऊं तो कैसे किया यहां पर मेरा विंडोज
था विंडो के ऊपर नेट कट लिनर हमने सेट अप
किया सर्वर मोड में और हमने सेट अप किया
कि जब भी यह जो अटैकर है अटैकर इसके साथ
कनेक्शन क्रिएट करेगा जैसे कनेक्शन बनाएगा
तो इसको
इसका कमांड प्रोमट मिल जाए और यही हुआ
हमारे सामने अभी हम उल्टा भी कर सकते हैं
कैसे वो भी मैं आपको दिखाता हूं कैसे कर
सकते हैं देखो आप अपोजिट करते इसको मैं
क्या करता हूं अभी एग्जिट कर देता हूं हिट
एंटर इसको एग्जिट कर दिया और दिस इज आवर
प्रम सेल ओके नाउ अभी हम क्या करते हैं
यहां पर लिन करते
हैं नेट कट हाइन एंड व एल प उसके बाद मैं
4444 प लेशन कर रहा हूं उसके बाद देन
डायरेक्टली अभी हाइ फन सी इसके केस में
यूज करेंगे हाइन सी हाइन सी बिन और
बैस और हिट एंटर सक्सेसफुली और हम क्या
करते य पर ये रहा नाउ नेट कट न ए एक्सी
बाइल लेने वाले एनवी टारगेट आईपी
19216801
देन 4444 हिट एंटर देखिए कनेक्टेड एंड
यहां पर हमें क्या है कनेक्शन क्रिएट हो
गया अगर आपको देखना है तो देखो एलस
रिमी नेटकट डमी ओके अगर मैं एक काम करता
हूं स्ल बिन स्ल बस इंटरेक्ट इव ओपन यूज़
करता हूं यहां पर h आ हिट एंटर यह
देखो ओके वहां पर कनेक्शन बंद हो गया ओके
फिर से हम इसको ओपन करते हैं हमने
कुछ ओके ओके यहां पर क्रिएट
हुआ ओके देखो वहां पर वहां पर काम कर रहा
है देखो एलएस कर रहा हूं यह देखो r me.dj
हम चलते रूट टटर य देखो सीडी रूट यहां पर
कमांड आपको देखने को मिल रही है इधर यहां
पर सीडी रूट उसके बाद एलस देखो डेस्कटॉप
टेंपलेट यह चीज आपको देखने को मिल रही है
गेटिंग पट सबको समझ में आ रहा
हैके फरवाल ने डिटेक्ट कर लिया विंडो
डिफेंडर ने और ब्लॉक कर दिया उसको इसलिए
इशू हो गया आपके विंडो डिफाइनर ने उसको
ब्लॉक कर दिया इसलिए इशू क्रिएट हो गया
ओके समझ में
आया एवरीवन बांड सेल सबको समझ में आया या
नहीं आया
बताओ एवरीवन क्लियर बाइ एंड
सेल दोनों के केस में मैंने आपको बता
दिया अगर कोई रिवर्सल ले रखा है मेरे
सिस्टम से क्या मैं भी उस उसी समय अटैक के
रिवर्स सेल ले सकता
हूं तो एक काम कर सकते हो ना आपको पता है
कोई रिवर्स सेल क्रिएट कर रखा है किसी ने
तो रिवर्स सेल के लिए कहीं ना कहीं तो
उसकी फाइल आपके मशीन के ऊपर डाउनलोड हुई
है तो उस फाइल को मॉडिफाई करके आप एक कोड
और ऐड कर दो खुद का भी उस साइड से व आपका
रिवर्स सेल ले और आप उसका ले लो सिंपल
देखि सीएमडी ड आपकी कमांड प्रोमट की फाइल
है बिन बेस आपकी बेस फाइल है नक्स के लिए
आपकी बाइनरी फाइल कौन सी है नॉर्मली सेल
फाइल कौन सी है बिन बैस है या स्ल बिन एस
है लेकिन विंडोज के केस में आपकी सीडी है
एग्जीक्यूटेबल फाइल ट दिस इ द डिफरेंस
बिटवीन जो आपको ब्लैक कलर का जो कमांड
प्रम दिख रहा है ना यह रहा यह रहा य आपकी
विन एक्ससी है ओके विड्स फाइल है
चलो
अभी आगे बढ़े रिवर सेल के बारे में बात
करें रिव सेल के बारे में बात करते हैं
थोड़ा सा ना अभी हम बात करते हैं रिवर सेल
के बारे में कि रिवर सेल होता क्या
है बाइन सेल सबको क्लियर
ओके अभी रिवर्स सेल होता क्या है ए रिवर्स
सेल इज ए टाइप ऑफ रिमोट सेल वेर द वेर द
टारगेट कनेक्ट डायरेक्टली टू ए लिनर ऑन द
अटैकर सिस्टम एंड कंसीक्वेंटली अलांग फॉर
एग्जीक्यूशन ऑफ कमांड ऑन द टारगेट सिस्टम
बेसिकली क्या है कि रिवर्स सेल भी एक एक
प्रकार का रिमोट सेल ही है लेकिन यहां पर
होता क्या है जो टारगेट सिस्टम है वह खुद
से कनेक्ट होता आपके अटैकर सिस्टम के साथ
और देन आप क्या करते हो वहां पर अपनी
कमांड रन करते हो ठीक है बाइ सेल के केस
में क्या था कि आप एक सर्वर सेट अप कर रहे
थे सर्वर मोड सेट अप कर रहे थे नेटकट की
हेल्प से टारगेट सिस्टम के ऊपर देन आप
उससे कनेक्शन बना रहे थे इन कनेक्शन यहां
पर आउट बाउंड कनेक्शन है यहां पर टारगेट
खुद से आपकी मशीन के साथ कनेक्ट हो रहा है
ओके तो नाउ देखिए अगर हम बात करें कि
रिवर्स इट इज वेरी इंपोर्टेंट टू नोट दैट
इन द कांटेक्ट ऑफ रिवर्स सेल द कनेक्शन
कैन एक्चुअली बी इनिशिएटिव विदाउट नेट कट
ओके अभी रिवर्स सेल की हम बात करें तो
हमेशा जो कनेक्शन है वह टारगेट सिस्टम के
द्वारा ही इनिशिएटिव साइल के केस में मतलब
यहां पर ये है यू नीड ए कनेक्शन बीइंग मेड
फ्रॉम टारगेट सिस्टम टू द लिनर अभी दैट इज
व्हाई रिवर्स सेल इज मच बेटर देन ए बाइन
सेल एंड द फैक्ट दैट यू डिड नॉट नीड टू
सेट अप ए लिनर ऑन द टारगेट सिस्टम ओके और
आपको टारगेट सिस्टम के ऊपर कोई भी लिस्नर
सेट अप करने की जरूरत नहीं है इसलिए
रिवर्स सेल मच बेटर देन ए बाइंडर एंड नॉट
नेसेसरी कि आपको नेट कैस्ट लिनर नेट कट के
थ्रू ही आप क्या कर सकते हो रिवर्स सेल ले
सकते हो ओके तो दिस इ यह रहा तो व्हाट इज
द इशू विद रिवर्स सेल अब रिवर्स सेल के
साथ भी एक इशू है उसके बारे में बात करते
हैं इन ऑर्डर टू मेक कनेक्शन द टारगेट
सिस्टम नीड द आईपी एड्रेस ऑफ द अटैकर
सिस्टम अब मुझे रिवर्स सेल क्रिएट करना है
किसी भी टारगेट सिस्टम के साथ तो मुझे
क्या करना होगा उसको अपना एज ए अटैकर मुझे
अटैकर का आईपी एड्रेस प्रोवाइड करना होगा
यह एक इशू है अभी अगर किसी को आप अपने
अटैकर का आईपी एड्रेस प्रोवाइड कर रहे हो
तो वो उससे बुरी कोई बात नहीं उसके दो
रीजंस है क्या हो सकता है देखो व्हिच इज
बैड फॉर टू रीजंस द एक्सप्लोइट दैट यू विल
बी यूजिंग विल एक्चुअली हैव टू फाइंड ए वे
ऑफ गेटिंग द टारगेट आईपी और ए टारगेट आईपी
ट्रांसफर्ट ओवर द मतलब जो एक्सप्लोइट आप
यूज करने वाले हो किसके लिए रिवर्स सेल के
लिए आपको उसको या तो बताना पड़ेगा कि आपको
टारगेट जो आईपी है कहां से मिलेगा कैसे
मिलेगा उसके लिए आपको कोड लिखना होगा या
आपको खुद से टारगेट आईपी को उस टारगेट
सिस्टम के ऊपर क्या करना पड़ेगा ट्रांसफर
करना होगा या हार्ड कोडेड उसके अंदर
प्रोवाइड करना होगा एक तो यह कारण है द
अदर इशू विद दैट द अटैकर्स आईपी इज़ देन
लिक्ड र मेड पब्लिक जिसकी वजह से आपका
क्या होगा जो सबसे बड़ा इशू है आपका आईपी
एड्रेस लीक हो जाएगा पब्लिकली अवेलेबल हो
जाएगा जिससे ऑल दीज थिंग्स यू नीड टू बी
कीप्स इन योर माइंड इफ एक्सप्लोइट फाइल इज
करेंटली ऑन द डिस्क ऑन टारगेट सिस्टम अगर
जो एक्सप्लोइट फाइल है अगर वह टारगेट
सिस्टम की डिस्क के ऊपर है क्योंकि आप
डाउनलोड करते हो देन दैट केस फाइल कंटेन द
अटैकर्स आईपी उस केस में अगर आपकी फाइल है
उसके अंदर अटैकर्स का आईपी एड्रेस है तो
क्या होगा जो सिक्योरिटी एनालिस्ट है वो
आपको
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
अटैक कर सकते हैं तो दैट इज द रीजन कि
आपको जब रिवर्स सेल यूज कर रहे हो ये आपको
पता होना चाहिए कि आप रिवर्स सेल यूज करने
के बाद आपको अपने ट्रैक हमेशा क्लियर करने
ही पड़ेंगे अदर वाइज यू गेट गट क्योंकि
वहां पर आपका आईपी एड्रेस अवेलेबल हो
क्योंकि आपको रिवर्स कनेक्शन क्रिएट करना
है तो आपको आईपी प्रोवाइड करना ही पड़ेगा
आपने मशीन को या अपने एक्सप्लोइट कोड
को ओके तो वन ऑफ द ग्रेट फीचर अबाउट
रिवर्स सेल इ यू डोंट नीड टू हैव नेट कैट
लिनर ऑन द एक्चुअल टारगेट सिस्टम सबसे
अच्छा फीचर यह है कि आपको जरूरी नहीं है
कि आपका नेट कैट लिनर होना चाहिए आपके
टारगेट सिस्टम के ऊपर द कनेक्शन टू द नेट
कट लिनर ऑन द अटैकर सिस्टम कैन बी मेड
थ्रू द यूज ऑफ पावर सेल कोड बैस कोड और
पाइथन कोड आप चाहो तो पावर सेल कोड बैस
कोड और पाइथन कोड की हेल्प से क्या कर
सकते हो लिनर सेट अप कर सकते हो या आप
क्या कर सकते हो रिवर्स सेल ले सकते हो
अपने टारगेट न का यू कैन आल्सो जनरेट
एग्जीक्यूटेबल दैट विल कनेक्ट टू दैट
पर्टिकुलर लिनर एंड प्रोवाइड यू विद ए
रिवर्स सेल ओके यह आप क्या कर सकते हो
स्क्रिप्ट लिख सकते हो खुद की और उनकी
हेल्प से क्या कर सकते हो आप रिवर्स सेल
क्रिएट कर सकते हो तो सो यू डोंट नीड टू
रिलाई ऑन नेट कट टू इनिशिएटिव
सेल के केस में तो अभी मैं आपको
प्रैक्टिकली दिखाता हूं कि नेटकट की हेल्प
से हम रिवर्स सेल कैसे क्रिएट कर सकते हैं
उसके बाद मैं आपको एक जगह बताऊंगा जहां पर
आपको सारे पेलोड मिल जाएंगे या खुद के भी
आप पेलोड क्रिएट कर सकते हो
ओके इसका सॉल्यूशन आपको अपने ट्रैक क्लियर
करने होंगे इसका सोल्यूशन यही है उस फाइल
को डिलीट करना होगा काम हो जाने के बाद
वहां पर उस फाइल को छोड़ नहीं सकते आप या
मेमोरी में एग्जीक्यूट करो और उसके बाद बस
डिस्क पर डाउनलोड मत करो उस फाइल को
यही एक तरीका है तो आपको अगर प्रैक्टिकली
दिखाऊ तो मैं य यह हमारी मशीन है और अभी
यह हमारा रिवर्स सेल आपको क्रिएट करके
दिखाऊंगा यह मेरा पैरेट ओके तो क्लियर कर
देते हैं हम य पर लिनर लिसनिंग एनवी एल प
उसके बाद हाइन हम य क्या करेंगे एनवी प और
हाइ
फन ओके ओ ओके एन सी
हाइन एन व एल प ओके टूथ 4 यहां पर मैं
क्या कर रहा हूं मेरा नेट कट लिनर इज
लिसनिंग ओके मैं लिसनिंग लिसनिंग मोड में
हूं और यहां पर मैं क्या कर रहा अभी
रिवर्स सेल क्रिएट करूंगा फ डायरेक्टली
देखो एनसी उसके बाद हाइन एनवी उसके बाद
क्या है हमारा टारगेट आईपी
192.168 22 यहां पर मैं क्या कर रहा हूं
खुद सेड 1660
160 ओके 160 पोर्ट है 1 2 3 4 उसके बाद
हान e हान e क्या कर रहा हूं मैं यहां पर
यह रहा h e cmd.exe यह मैं क्या कर रहा
हूं रिवर्स सेल है हीट एंटर यहां पर
रिवर्स सेल है समझ में आया यह मैं पहले कर
चुके हैं क्योंकि यहां पर आपका नेट कट
लिस्नर ऑन था यहां पर यह क्या है आपका
रिवर्स सेल आपने खुद से क्या किया है
कनेक्शन क्रिएट किया है एक छोटा सा
एग्जांपल आपका रिवर्स सेल का अब उसके बाद
आपको चीट चट बताता हूं कि आपको रिवर्स
सेल्स बाकी कहां से मिलेंगे फॉर एग्जांपल
यह देखिए
अभी मैं आपको दिखाता हूं
कि यह रेख तो है आपकी चीट सट आपकी यह है
पेलोड ऑल द
थिंग्स
पेलोड थस यह
रहा अ पलो न थिंग इसके अंदर आपको जाना
[संगीत]
है इसके अंदर आपको जाना
है लॉजी एंड ये रहा मैथोलॉजी एंड
रिसोर्सेस यहां पर आपको अवेलेबल मिल
जाएंगे देखो यहां पर सारे के सारे इसके
अंदर आपको मिलेगा रिवर्स सेल चीट शीट
रिवर्स सेल चीट शट मिलेगा यहां पर ये रहा
रिवर्स सेल चीटशीट एमडी ये रही ये आपके
रिवर्स सेल चीट शट है आपको लिंक प्रोवाइड
कर देता हूं कंट्रोल सी और यहां क्या कर
सकते हो आप यह
रहा एक तो यह रहा कंट्रोल व ना एक तो ये
लिंक य है यहां पर सारे के सारे पे लोड
आपके अवेलेबल जैसे फॉर
एग्जांपल बेस्ट टीसीपी बेस्ट यूडीपी अगर
आपका
[संगीत]
विंडोज ओनली विंडोज ओनली पीएचपी के अगर
आपके पास वेबसाइट है और आप वेबसाइट के
थ्रू क्या करना चाहते हो रिवर्स सेल लेना
चाहते हो तो यह रहा पीएचपी के रिवर्स सेल
अवेलेबल है रूबी के बेस पर रस्ट के बेस पर
गो लैंग्वेज के बेस पर नेटकट से नेटकट की
आपको पता है देखो नेट एनसी हान ई बिन यह र
देखो यह ऑलरेडी हम कर चुके हैं नेटकट ओपन
बीएसडी एन कट ओपन एसएसएल यह रहा पावर सेल
के भी है देखो यहां पर पावर सेल के भी
यहां पर देखो ू यह रहा यह रहा यह रहा यह
रहा नाउ देखिए पावर पावर सेल से रिलेटेड
है यह
देखो
देखो समझ रहे पावर सेल के थ्रू भी आप क्या
कर सकते हो कनेक्शन ले सकते हो नाउ देखो
आप चाहो तो इसको यूज करके देख सकते हो अगर
काम करेगी तो यह रहा कॉपी टू क्लिप बोर्ड
नाउ उसके बाद अभी हम इसको क्या कंट्रोल सी
एंड क्लियर क्लियर काम करता नहीं कंट्रोल
शिफ्ट व नाउ इसके अंदर काम करेगा नहीं
पेस्ट काम करेगा ओके पावर सेल है अभी इसको
हम थोड़ा सा मॉडिफाई करना पड़ेगा
डायरेक्टली रन नहीं कर सकते ना इसको हम
देखो इसको थोड़ा सा मॉडिफाई करना पड़ेगा
लेकिन य पावर
सेल नहीं यहां पर हमें पावर सेल ही यूज
करनी पड़ेगी अरवा वी विल ट्राई
इट ओके ओके ओके यह रहा हमारा आईपी एड्रेस
क्या है यहां
पर
192.168
[संगीत]
0160 4242 नाउ वी विल ट्राइट इफ इट्स वर्क
लिनर
प
4242 ट एंटर एंड नाउ अभी देखो हो गया हिट
एंटर
और इट्स वर्किंग और नॉट वर्किंग आई डोंट
नो यह
रहा नॉट वर्किंग क्योंकि कई बार क्या होता
है उसके लिए हमें क्या करना पड़ेगा कुछ
इसका मॉडिफिकेशन करना पड़ेगा इधर
ओके हां मोबाइल में भी रिवर्स ले सकते हो
लेकिन उसका तरीके अलग है ओके तो ये रहा
देखो अभी इसम नॉट लिसनिंग क्योंकि अभी काम
नहीं कर रहा एक और है मैनुअल तरीका आप
क्या कर सकते हो एक तो यहां से आप कोई भी
रिवर्स सेल के एक्सप्लोइट क्रिएट कर सकते
हो अपने कोड के अंदर यूज कर सकते हो एक और
है एक होता आपका आप खुद के रिवर्स सेल
जनरेट कर सकते हो जैसे कि यह आपका है
एचटीटीपीएस मैंने लिखे हुए हैं सारे के
सारे
डड
डॉट रिवर्स
सेल
रिव
सेल सेल्स कॉ
यह रहा आप यहां पर खुद का क्रिएट कर सकते
हो देखो यहां पर खुद का आईपी एड्रेस मेंशन
करोगे देखो ये रहा
192.168 0.10 ओके पोर्ट आप कौन सा यूज
करना चाहते हो फॉर एग्जांपल टूथ 4 यूज
करना चाहता हूं ओके अभी टाइप एंड अब कौन
सी यूटिलिटी का यूज करना चाहते हो लिनर के
लिए एनसी एन कट n कट र स्कन ओपन एसएसएल
अभी मैं क्या एनसी का यूज करना चाहता हूं
नाउ अभी यहां पर देखो टाइप ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम के बेस पर linux.com
और
कंट्रोल कॉपी और इसका हमें यूज करना पड़े
है हाइन एलवी एन प टूथ 4 यूज करना पड़ेगा
अभी के लिए हम इसको क्या करते हैं अभी
पेस्ट हमने यहां पर खुद से क्रिएट किया है
यह
रहा टूथ 4 यह रहा और अभी के लिए हम इसको
यूज करेंगे हिट
एंटर यह देखो नॉट एल डलर एल होस्ट इ नॉट
रिकॉग्नाइज एज इंटरनल एक्सटर्नल कमांड ओके
मतलब अभी इसके लिए हमें क्या कि बहुत सारे
चेंजेज भी करने पड़ सकते हैं जिसको पावर
सेल आएगी पावर सेल के हिसाब से आपको
चेंजेज करने होंगे यह
देखो पावर सेल टू यह वाला यूज करके देख
सकते हो य देखो यह वाला यूज करके देख सकते
हो आप
कॉपी नाउ और अभी देखते हैं
इट्स वर्किंग और नॉट वर्किंग देखो इ
ट्रांग टू देखो यह रहा यह रहा यह रहा
कनेक्ट हो गया यह रहा कनेक्ट हो गया
है देखो इट्स कनेक्टेड इट्स वर्किंग देख
रहे हो आपके
सामने आपके सामने मैंने यहां पर क्या किया
देखो पावर सेल मैनुअली क्रिएट किया हु
एक्स पलेट य रहा पावर सेल टू वाला ये एक्स
पलेट हमने यूज किया नेट काट लिसन अपने टूथ
4 पर यूज किया देन बूम वी
सक्सेसफुली हैक दिस मशीन देखो
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर सेल हु एम आई ये रहा आगे
आपको देखना है सिस्टम इंफॉर्मेशन
सिस्टम इंफॉर्मेशन
देखो यह रहा इट विल टेक टाइम बट यहां पर
दे सिस्टम
इंफो ओके सबको समझ में आ गया
एवरीवन दिस इज द कांसेप्ट आप बता देता हूं
ये रहा मैं आपको ये भी लिंक प्रोवाइड कर
देता हूं कि आप खुद से रिवर्स सेल भी
क्रिएट कर सकते हो खुद के रिवर्स सेल
क्रिएट कर सकते
हो ओके तो आप एक काम सबसे मोस्ट प्रेफर्ड
मैं आपको जगह बताई है पेलोड ऑल द थिंग्स
आप ट्रस्ट आप ऐसे डायरेक्टली ट्रस्ट नहीं
करना आपको और आप ही एक बात बताए पेलोड ऑल
द थिंग्स में तो आप क्या कर रहे हो खुद
किसी को हैक करने के लिए पलो ट्राई कर रहे
हो ना अपनी मशीन पे तो रन नहीं कर रहे
तो अपनी मशीन पर मत रन कीजिए
ओके अपनी मशीन पर रन मत कीजिए तो जो मैं
आपको बताया r.com यह वाली यह सबसे बेस्ट
लगी मेरे को मोस्टली ये यूज भी की जाती है
और आप इसको यूज भी कर सकते देखो खुद का
आईपी एड्रेस ऐड करो पोर्ट ऐड करो यह खुद
से आपके सामने एक स्क्रिप्ट क्रिएट करके
दे देगा चाहे जावा में भी कर सकते हो
जावास्क्रिप्ट में भी गवी में भी यह तो
ओनली विंडोज थे आप चाहो तो
में देखो आप आप बेस यूज करो तो ये बेस के
हैं बेस 196 बेस रीड लाइन बेस यूडीपी देन
एनसी नेट कट कर्ल देखो कर्ल के भी यहां पर
अवेलेबल है रस स्कैन ओपन एसएसएल के थ्रू
भी आप क्या कर सकते हो ट्राई कर सकते हो
तोय दे आर लॉट ऑफ पावर सेल रिवर्स सेल
जनरेटर जिनका आप यूज कर सकते हो एक पे
डिपेंडेंट मत रहिए इस पे अलग-अलग ट्राई
करके देखिए अकॉर्डिंग टू योर वल्नरेबल तो
आपको सक्सेस रेट मिल सकती है आपको सक्सेस
होने के चांसेस हैं तो एवरीवन क्लियर यहां
तक किसी को कोई डाउट
है यह स्क्रिप्ट तो हर कोई अभी देखो क्या
होता है राजू कि आपके पास पेलोड्स है और
हर कोई आपको क्या बता दे पेलोड बता देगा
टूल्स बता देगा कि आप पेलोड ऐसे जनरेट कर
सकते हो ताकि आपको खुद से पेलोड जनरेट ना
करने पड़े अभी फिर डिपेंड करता है कि आप
उसको कैसे डिलीवर कर सकते हो आप
डायरेक्टली किसी भी मशीन के ऊपर आप पेलोड
को भेजोगे तो आप डिटेक्ट हो जाओगे पकड़े
जाओगे उसके लिए आप डिपेंड करता है कि किसी
फाइल में छुपा के भेजना चाहते हो फ स्केट
करोगे या वो फिर आप पर डिपेंड करता है कि
आपको उस पेलोड को छुपाना है और वो टेक्निक
आपको आनी चाहिए समझ रहे हो पेलोड यही है
जो यूज कर रहे हैं डेली लेकिन फिर भी लोग
सक्सेस रेट 100% कैसे ले लेते हैं ताकि
कैसे क्योंकि वह क्या करते हैं ऑफ स्केट
करते हैं या वो अपनी खुद की टेक्निक्स
उनके पास जो शेयर नहीं करना चाहते कौन
शेयर कर क्योंकि आपके टेक्निक किसी को पता
चल जाएगी और एक दिन फिर आपकी टेक्निक्स भी
एंटीवायरस या आपके जो सिक्योरिटी सोल्यूशन
पकड़ लेंगे कौन अपनी टेक्निक सो आपके
सामने शो करेगा तो एवरीवन गट क्लियर सबको
समझ में आ
गया किसी का कोई डाउट है रिलेटेड टू द
क्लास किसी कोई सवाल है कोई कंप्लेन है
कोई शिकायत है
मैं आपको बेसिक इजन का थोड़ा बताऊंगा कि
एक सिग्नेचर बेस्ड इ वेजन कैसे करते हैं
बेसिक लेवल पर बताऊंगा बट एडवांस लेवल
पर तो मैं नहीं बताऊंगा आपको व आपको पेड
में सीखना पड़ेगा और वैसे भी कोई भी आपको
टेक्निक बताएगा ना बट वह अपनी खुद की
टेक्निक नहीं बताएगा सच बात है मैं भी इवन
अपनी खुद की टेक्निक नहीं बताऊंगा क्योंकि
क्या होता है कि स्टूडेंट्स क्या करते
टेक्निक को जब अभी क्या है मैं आपको जो
पढ़ा ब्लाइली वही करोगे वो टेक्निक आप
बलाली फॉलो करते हो तो अभी क्या की अब
मेरे लिए सक्सेस उसकी कम हो जाती
है इजन की भी
सबकी सबके अभी सक्सेस रेट मैं अपनी क्यों
अपनी अपनी खराब करूंगा क्योंकि मैं आपको
बता दूंगा कि कॉमन टेक्निक्स क्या होती है
कॉमनली हम कैसे कर कर सकते हैं लेकिन वह
खुद से आपको टेक्निक क्रिएट करनी होगी हिट
एंड ट्रायल वही
ना चूहे और बिल्ली का खेल होता है
एंटीवायरस के खेल में बस और हर किसी में
काम नहीं करता सबकी अपनी टेक्निक होती है
खुद की बस आप एक साथ सारे के सारे
एंटीवायरस बायपास नहीं कर सकते एक बार में
एक ही कर सकते हो मूवी नहीं चल रही यह
रियल लाइफ सिनेरियो है यहां पर आपको एक
बार में एक ही करना है उसके लिए आपके पास
सॉलिड इंफॉर्मेशन होनी
चाहिए एडवांस कोर्स तो यार इसके बाद ही
आएगा मैं एडवांस कोर्स को वर्कशॉप के केस
में मतलब वर्कशॉप बनाऊंगा छोटे-छोटे
वर्कशॉप में डिलीवर करूंगा एडवांस को
एडवांस नहीं प्रोफेशनल डिलीवर करूंगा मैं
छोटे छोटे वर्कशॉप बनाऊंगा उन वर्कशॉप की
ड्यूरेशन होगी 10 15 डेज या वन वीक उसमें
मैं डिलीवर करूंगा वोह पेड वर्कशॉप होंगे
वर्कशॉप में मजा आता है फिर
भी सीसीएनए मैंने नहीं किया सीसीएन का बस
जस्ट बेसिक लेवल का मैंने अपनी सेल्फ
स्टडी के लिए पढ़ा हुआ बट मैंने सीसीने
नहीं किया
जल्दी आ जाएगा आपके
सामने आप बिगनर हो तो आप एक काम कीजिए
आपके पास पहले इस कोर्स को फॉलो कीजिए
स्टार्टिंग डे वन से वीडियो देखिए आप डे
वन से पूरे कोर्स को पढ़िए क्योंकि ये
बिल्कुल जीरो टू इंटरमीडिएट है मतलब मैंने
जो चीजें रिक्वायरमेंट है बिल्कुल बेसिक
लेवल पर सब कुछ आपको बताया है फिर भी आपको
लगता है नहीं मुझे आउट ऑफ मेमोरी है तो
आपको फंडामेंटल नॉलेज ऑफ पीसी फंडामेंटल
नॉलेज ऑफ नेटवर्किंग और फंडामेंटल नॉलेज
सबकी होनी चाहिए धीरे-धीरे एक्सप्लोइट
क्या होता है या बेसिक जो नॉलेज होती है
रिलेटेड टू साइबर सिक्योरिटी फंडामेंटल
साइबर सिक्योरिटी फंडामेंटल आईटी बोल सकते
हैं स्विच कैसे काम करते हैं यह नेटवर्क
यह सारे फंडामेंटल नॉलेज के बाद अगर आप
यहां पर एंटर करोगे तो आपके लिए सही रहेगा
ओके तो
शायद
बताइए और नेक्स्ट क्लास में आपको पहले
हिंट प्रोवाइड कर देता हूं
प्लीज आना क्योंकि नेक्स्ट क्लास जो रहेगी
पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन की जो टेक्निक होती
है ना पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन की लोकल नमरे
कि अगर आपने किसी मशीन को हैक कर लिया
आपने हैक कर लिया हैक करने के बाद आपको
फिर से क्या फर्द एक्सप्लोइट करना है ना
अभी हैक करने के बाद आप उस मशीन के ऊपर
लोकल नमरे परफॉर्म करते हो कि नक्स है तो
है और अगर उसको सलूशन मैं आपको प्रोवाइड
नहीं करूंगा लेकिन आप बोलोगे तो मैं उसको
सॉल्व करके दिखा दूंगा क्लास के
स्टार्टिंग के 20 मिनट में और उसके बाद
नेक्स्ट टॉपिक हम स्टार्ट कर सकते हैं एंड
में हम उसको सॉल्व कर सकते हैं सीटीएफ को
अदर वाइज एक सीटीएफ आपको मैज टास्क
प्रोवाइड करूंगा नेक्स्ट क्लास में और
आपको टॉपिक मैंने बता दिया बी रेडी और
बिल्कुल फुल फ्रेश माइंड से आना नेक्स्ट
क्लास में
नो आईडिया इनोस और पपो जैसी कंपनी का
हायरिंग प्रोसेस क्या रहता है भाई मुझे सच
में कोई आईडिया
नहीं ओके तो फिर भी कोई डाउट है किसी का
तो मुझसे पूछ सकते हो अदर वाइज हम सेशन को
एंड करते हैं
किसी कोई डाउट
है स्टिल एनी वन हैव एनी डाउट रिलेटेड टू
द क्लास या बेसिक डाउट मुझसे पूछ सकता है
अभी
करण पाल बोल रहे सर ऑफलाइन कोचिंग तो करण
पाल सिंह आपके पास
अगर ज्यादा पैसे हैं तो ऑफलाइन में जाइए
और आपको अगर नॉलेज मिल जाए तो आई विल
गारंटी की आपको इस लेवल की नॉलेज अगर आपको
मैं जो फ्री में पढ़ा रहा हू ना अगर
ऑफलाइन में आप लेकर दिखा दोगे ना तो मैं
आपको उसके पैसे पे
करूंगा मैं बोल रहा हूं नहीं पढ़ाते ला
ऑफलाइन में
ऐसे
ओके नहीं आई विल नॉट रिकमेंड सीसीएनए
बिकॉज यू आर नॉट ए नेटवर्क गाइस बट अगर आप
सीसीएनए के जो कांसेप्ट है उनको बस पढ़
लीजिए एक बार गो थ्रू कीजिए कि शौक में
जरूरत पड़ती है आपको नेटवर्किंग की
ज्यादा तो ओके बाय बाय टेक केयर एंड सी यू
फॉर नेक्स्ट सेशन गुड नाइट एंड फिर मिलते
हैं नेक्स्ट क्लास में बाय बाय टेक केयर